man there's so much
going on today i mean we're probably
going to see massive riots
in many cities tonight we'll see how
that plays out it's already 8 p.m
there's already been some protests i've
seen in minnesota
it might chill out throughout the rest
of the week and then pick up again this
weekend which is really bad
because the chauvin deliberations should
be taking place early next week
we think so far we'll see how it plays
out but we do got man
one of the biggest stories and it's
always really hard to properly provide
commentary on a story from project
veritas for one simple reason
which i will tell you in a second
project veritas has released undercover
footage of a cnn technical director
saying that they were just trying to get
donald trump out of office
that they effectively produce propaganda
they're going to be producing fear
content to push a climate change
narrative and you know why it's really
hard to provide commentary on this
because i'm just like when i see this
story i'm like oh yeah i know
don't you don't we all know cnn is doing
this i get it
veritas has gotten us the receipts and
this is a massive story which broke over
like 2.2 million views and only a couple
of hours it's been trending all day
because now we have it now we can see it
coming out of their mouths
james o'keefe calls one of these guys at
cnn they hang up the phone on them of
course
this is what they do unfortunately as
much as this
is this is huge project veritas will
they be able to break that news to
regular people who are still
hooked in to the cnn narrative that's
the challenge so that's what we need to
talk about when you talk about what this
guy said why he said it and i'll tell
you what's interesting
when i saw this story hit local abc
affiliate
a local abc affiliate i'm like okay this
story is big this this expose is big so
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
what's going on
with this woman in the dante right
shooting in minnesota she's expected to
be charged criminally
tomorrow we may very well see some more
protests in the meantime
joining us is commentary writer tom
rogan
good to be with you thank you tim just
briefly introduce yourself sure yeah so
i'm a commentary writer for the
washington examiner predominantly
focus on national security and foreign
policy uh
dual citizen so i'm not just a british
invader talking about american politics
um yeah and that's that's the short of
it and and ufo expert i'm kidding yeah
yeah
i i well i do take an interest yeah in
uh ufos or uaps
um you know because something really is
going on there and
and you know i think i have pretty good
sourcing on it and
a lot of journalists don't want to touch
it and there's just there's another
story that's been that's been
circulating for the past couple of weeks
there are like these tic tac
unidentified vehicles flying above naval
vessels apparently
now there's footage of it so yeah we'll
get in all that we'll talk about that uh
later on of course we've got ian he's
ian crossland coming at you with a
periodic table in one hand and a cup of
coffee in the other ready to talk about
meta materials with tom
right and ufo machines but also let's
talk about things happening on earth
yeah that's that's fair
yeah i sent tom this link uh talking to
him about the project veritasy and he's
like
yeah we know about cnn and i was like
yeah but it's like big because they said
it themselves
anyway i'm in the corner pushing buttons
as always our bachelorettes that's the
big challenge like breaking news
everyone
cnn is producing lies and propaganda and
they're like that's not breaking news
but but veritas got the guy on camera
this time
2.2 million views doesn't matter that's
huge
that's huge all right we'll talk about
this before we get started my friends go
over to timcast.com and become a member
to get exclusive to get access to
exclusive members only segments we
recently updated the website we're still
building it out we're still trying to
improve upon it
and uh get things smooth and smoothed
out but if you go to tps.com
become a member you're helping support
the show in the event that we get banned
or whatever so
don't forget if you're uh listening on
itunes or spotify leave us a good review
give us five stars all that stuff and
for everybody else on youtube smash that
like button it really helps
subscribe because we're we're like
couple thousand subscribers away from
breaking one million on this show and
that will be really really awesome so
you know special thank you to everybody
who's watching i got one more thing to
mention
many people have been clamoring for that
i am a gorilla tinfoil hat shirt
so if you go to timcast.com right up at
the top you can see that shop button if
you click
click it you can see we got here the
limited edition
tinfoil gorilla it will probably only be
up until the remainder of this week
because i think it'll have been up then
for about two weeks and then we're
probably gonna take this one down
because we have a ton of the gorilla
shirts and maybe even the diamond hands
gorilla will probably come down and
we'll just keep the original gorilla
shirt
so get them while you you can because
we're gonna have more shirts coming up
and don't forget
smash that subscribe button smash that
like button let's read this first
story from abc 13 wham
project veritas says it caught cnn
staffer
admitting network pushed anti-trump
propaganda this is an
abc affiliate reporting this which if if
local news outlets are picking up
project veritas the story is pretty big
they say veritas unveiled a video
tuesday that says that the group says is
of a cnn staffer describing how the
network worked to show then presidential
candidate joe biden in a favorable light
during the 2020 campaign
the undercover video captured a man the
self-proclaimed conservative watchdog
group identified
as cnn technical director charlie
chester i'm not sure
veritas has ever self-proclaimed to be
conservative watchdogs but i digress
saying he decided to work with the
network because it focused on removing
former president donald trump chester
also credited cnn as a critical tool in
electing biden
quote look what we did we got
we cnn got trump out i am 100 going to
say it and i 100
believe that if it wasn't for cnn i
don't know that trump would have got
voted out
i came to cnn because i wanted to be a
part of that the man said in one portion
of the video
chester was speaking to someone off
camera at undisclosed locations
he was targeted through the dating app
tinder according to mediaite
that is impressive work from project
veritas
how do they do that tinder is random it
shows you a person
so they have they so james o'keefe has
got young women like
swiping right on these dudes like just
scouring tinder looking for someone
saying i work at cnn boom
well that's a foreign intelligence way
you know you you ever if you just do
mass you know spread and then you can
target it down
as you find the person i'm impressed if
they if they really did use tinder to
get access to these these guys that
means veritas does
more substantive investigative work than
i realized yeah good tradecraft or it
could have been a girl that just met
some dude was like oh you work for cnn
oh i gotta get in touch with project
veritas about that
i gotta say you know if they're
reporting that i really believe it
because you have to wonder
how it is they consistently get access
to some of these people they're not just
like walking into places and being like
hi tell me all your secrets
going on a date with some dude and
having him spill the beans now i will
say you gotta be careful about one thing
could this guy be hamming it up because
he's trying to get laid
well definitely yeah for sure yes of
course
is is she like i hate trouble because i
hate trump too yeah in fact
yeah yeah and then she's like yeah yeah
like wouldn't it be cool like cnn helped
help get him out he's oh yeah cnn
definitely did that i did that that's
why i'm here
right back to my place yeah that's
almost why we need the kind of body
camera right with the police officer
before
they pull up yeah right that you want do
you want the totality of the
circumstances but
you know what though i will i will say
um there there was one
undercover video that project veritas
got with a guy i'm not gonna name
that i knew and they had a young woman
talking to this guy
and the guy was saying all this stuff
about what he could do at the new york
times or whatever
and i'm like dude he is hamming it up he
is trying to impress this lady
he's talking smack and i'll say it right
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna chill for
veritas in every circumstance i'll
criticize him if
i see some some reason to do it but this
is different
this is a news this is someone who's
working for cnn a technical director
who has no problem telling members of
the public be it is he lying to this
young woman about what cnn does
he's he's confident enough for whatever
reason to say
cnn produces fear we propagandize
and our goal was political i said it
that's it
and i i do think one of the challenges
here though for cnn and of course it
applies to other outlets is that you
know
on one side you do have we saw it in the
campaign uh
obviously um very anti-trump coverage
very pro-biden
um and the other side you know certainly
some of their foreign policy
correspondents uh kylie atkins you know
jim schudo who i think has sort of moved
more in the opinion inside
you know do really good reporting so
it's a it it's a challenge for them in a
sense right that they
that this you know because this is not
great for their
you know credibility well the outlets
and it's sort of unfair on them in a
sense
i don't think they care i think you know
you turn on reliable sources today and
what's oliver darcy and brian
talk stealth are talking about who's the
right wing boogeyman today i jokingly
you know i'll tweet it brian selter
that he's the host of the fox news
review show right because you turn on
sunday morning with cnn and it's brian
brian styles are telling you what fox
news is talking about i'm like what is
this
how is this in any way news about the
media environment tucker carlson said
something offensive
and i'm like okay what's going on with
the me are there layoffs is the business
growing
what are journalists doing no it's just
basically cnn's like hey we can make
money because people don't like fox news
and there you go in a sense though you
know brian stelter's media show it's not
so much like how how he curts on fox
it's sort of i think more become
kind of laura ingram right there or sean
hannity that it's a more overtly opinion
show
yeah that that's presenting itself as a
media show absolutely absolutely and
and and i'll say that you know with
respect he's allowed to do that right if
he wants to be an opinion show if he
wants to be the sunday morning version
of hannity for the left or whatever
right
the only problem is you know when sean
hannity rags on the liberal media
there's many different liberal medias to
rag on right the fox news
is almost one of a kind i mean for cable
news it basically is
when me when reliable sources you know
cnn
just talks about fox news all day every
day i'm like i i i'm just i'm not
i don't see the urgency here man you
know what i mean it's one channel i know
they got a big viewership
but when you combine cbs abc nbc msnbc
hln cnn etc
i mean we're looking at 30 40 50 million
views or whatever
and then fox news they're huge you know
three million views
they're rivaling you know rachel maddow
and they're they're
bouncing back and forth between cnn and
the rate beating cnn the ratings
but you combine all of these media
outlets in their bias fox news doesn't
really
reach that level so it's like cnn doing
that show is
really weird in my opinion but more to
the point
cnn's coverage has been just just just
absolutely awful along with many of
these other outlets
now we're hearing this guy say all this
stuff i'm just kind of like
you know i have something i call the cnn
challenge i did call the cnn challenge
you can't really do it anymore because
trump's not president
but i would i'm somebody who watches the
news and i would turn out
i used to watch cnn i used to leave cnn
running in the background so i'd have
some like breaking news you know here's
what's happening
and then just one day i'm like are they
talking about trump again
so i switched to fox news and they're
like protests erupt in iran
you know tehran you know protesters in
tehran are doing and i'm like wow this
is big
and then i'd switch back to cnn like but
trump what you need to understand about
trump and i'm like okay
so i did it several times one point fox
news is like hong kong protests erupt
china's moving in turn to cnn now donald
trump is i even turned to cnn to fox
news once and like a big winter storm is
headed our way everyone you need to
buckle down turn to cnn
oh donald trump and so i just called it
the trump challenge because that's
basically what their their you know
their bread and butter
now take all of that information and
someone made a really interesting point
with this cnn cnn technical director
stating in numerous videos
we were activists we were trying to get
the president out the goal was political
we produced propaganda
some people have said that fulfills the
actual malice standard
now allowing donald trump to sue cnn for
defamation
because you have a cnn staffer a
director on the record saying
yeah we're full of it you know can you
use this guy's
is it testimony is this considered what
is it can you use this guy's statements
as like in a court of law
i don't know i'm not a lawyer no that he
i mean they would have to get him tested
i i don't think there's any chance of
that the actual malice standard
you know new york times solomon which is
the case
especially the federal courts uh the
judiciary in terms of the case on this
has been very predisposed
uh towards deference towards media
speech and i think that's the way to go
and i just for them they would have to
show number one that was representative
of cnn uh and of who spoke in the first
place exactly did he have the authority
as an agency to to say that and who
and and the individual who reported say
donald trump you know
you know punched a goat or something
right was it the same person
right did that person genuinely believe
they're telling the truth so it's not so
cut and dry
but i actually i i i agree with i agree
to assert
i agree to a certain degree that
protecting speech for the media is
important
in that sometimes there's a legitimate
attempt at reporting news
you make a mistake and if we sued every
time someone got something wrong
there wouldn't be news outlets right
news outlets should correct and that
i guess that was the the the intent was
like well you know they can just correct
the record but there's no obligation to
do it
that's problem number one if cnn writes
fake news
and donald trump says please correct
this they can say
no then you know trump or somebody will
file a defamation suit
and the judge will say anti-slap you're
dismissed get out
so how do you correct the record when
these news outlets are lying and you
can't break through that
that you know actual male standard that
barrier well i i think the ultimate
correction point you would hope and and
certainly i believe it is
is that you know credibility is lost
right that you the consumer ultimately
gets to decide what they want with news
right you have people watching this show
you have people watching cnn whatever
their reasons you have
people reading across the gamut of news
and commentary
and that ultimately we would hope uh
that that people decide actually when
they see stuff coming out and a lack of
responsibility right people are willing
to forgive mistakes
uh that perhaps it's not the place for
them to that's that's the inverse though
if cnn admits they were wrong they lose
credibility well they lose credibility
with their
most loyal base but i think if if they
don't admit they're wrong
then no the saliency of the fact well
that i think
i think you know people are talking
about i mean project veritas right
that it's out there i agree with you you
note earlier that
i think is absolutely true the um the
fact that fox news is in
its own at least in cable news kind of
ordinance and we see this right with
newsmax trying to break in there
and struggling to get on and we saw
actually you know it and it's it's
something
there's going to be a great battle in
the uk coming up with a couple of new
uh networks trying to break in there and
some of the lobbying already the bbc
they don't want that competition in
there
canada with um the sun news network that
wasn't able
to be viable because it wasn't able to
get on you know
providers yeah and and so yeah
it's a double-edged sword if if if you
can't force them to correct
we have a very serious problem because
then there's incentive to lie
they make money on the law if if they
write a fake news story
they could be sitting there thinking
like look the worst case scenario is we
try to rewrite a story saying donald
trump punches a you know baby goat
we're going to get 10 million views
we're gonna make you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars and if
we have to track tomorrow it's no big
deal
because you know what they make money on
their attraction as well yeah
and you know i think a broader challenge
there is that i used to think one of the
great solutions to this is
we have google news right that you can
read around and then i realized well
uh google news seems to be providing
some news outlets more equal than others
you know to borrow from orwell and and
it's really i mean it's true you know i
don't know oh yeah
and i don't know why uh well i have my
suspicions that there's an inherent bias
i actually emailed google about this and
they said
no no no our algorithms prevent that
from ever happening
okay i i'm not convinced that that might
be the case so
you know if as you say right people need
to be able to not only
access the news but know that
counterpoint exists and
people are busy right yes right so so
the problem i see is this
you hire a plumber you know when the
plumber doesn't fit your toilet
right so you're like hey buddy i need
you to come in and fix the toilet he
comes in and says your toilet's all
fixed and you're like all right you
flush it and then the water spills out
you're like it's not fixed right i can
see it's broken right
within with news you're hoping that what
they're telling you is the truth
after they come out and they say here's
your official news report on the middle
east
go ahead and read it you're like i i'm
assuming it's true
i just crossed my fingers and hope the
guy i hired to do the job is telling me
the truth
and often they're not they they do
clever tricks sometimes
it's the truth but you omit half the
information the story is very different
for instance
when trump the trump slump hit and the
ratings dropped
newsmax ratings go down cnn ratings go
down
what is cnn report news max ratings
collapse
but if they told you the truth
everyone's ratings went down
the reality was people in general are
just tired of news
by framing it only as newsmax they make
it seem like trump's
followers are losing faith or they're
not interested
in reality he had nothing to do with it
right that's just the manipulation it's
the framing technique
right no i mean it is and and you know i
do think though if if we look at um
the ability of um especially the younger
generation to access you know the
astuteness with which they are dealing
with technology
um uh and looking for
you know more creative even rebellious
um kind of outlooks
that dynamic um is only going to
continue to grow and i know that sounds
kind of basic and shallow and sort of
almost kind of kind of corporatist and
it's simplicity but it
if you look at foreign locales for
example the
the degree to which for example
clubhouse is performing at you know a
massive challenge to china
yeah that the census this industrial you
know ten
hundreds of thousands of people employed
to constrain flows of information
they can't because then there's a sub
club house and then there's you know
someone goes across
and uses a cutout isp and you know
and and certainly that that's what we've
been doing but the us was doing in iran
i think the
administration has actually cut it off
the cia program but
um well we were allowing iranians to
communicate
we were we were providing them with um
independent satellite
kind of you know internet as i
understand it yeah it's part of it it's
part of
it's part of a it's part of a covert
action program a trump administration
set up wow
i mean that seems like a good thing yeah
helping people communicate with each
other and
yeah human rights as well right yeah
trump supposedly didn't like that so
much but well biden must not be for
human rights i suppose
right well i'm starting to have a hard
time differentiating between
the onion and cnn and random youtuber
spouting who he hates and and loves like
it's it's all
becoming this this crap hole like just
just opinion and like is it even far is
it farce i can't even
tell you know what the funny thing is
the babylon b is
at this point i'm i'm going to wag my
finger they're not satire anymore you
know why
because they're actually reporting the
truth
but facetiously so they'll say something
like um what what i think that i think
it was the babylon be they put this out
they say
um after securing peace in the middle
east the u.s announces they'll withdraw
from afghanistan
because joe biden announced we're going
to be withdrawing from afghanistan
september hey i'm all for that thank you
joe biden
i mean it all right no i think he's
going to just throw him right back into
syria
so you know we got to make sure we're
going to stay vigilant on this one
but i do think it's funny when babylon b
reports a story
that it is satire they're making fun of
it but it's like
basically the truth but snarky
so that's like we're we're in such a
world of absurdity
that even now i mean they're they're the
look the bite administration is right
for parity especially right now
kyle kashuv tweeted i was told by so
many people that
if we voted for joe biden everything
would come back to normal and the
violence would stop you know so so where
where are we at guys the riots are
kicking back up everything's getting
worse
it is a world of parody man i do i do
think still and
of course my accent would suggest buyers
hit but i i'm trying to
you know be objective bbc news their
website
um i think it's still very good there is
of course
bias um the analytical when they have
some of the reporters doing their
analysis i think the bias comes through
them more
but the basic nuts and bolts reporting
on there
and the ability to kind of go in
different places a lot of that is
informed
by some of the world service stuff they
do um
and there are actually pretty good
structured checks and balances at bbc
and i i complained about a piece
um their russian bbc news wrote about me
about
an article i'd written a couple years
ago and you know they have a two-week
um you know respond to complaints goes
through a process
so of course the counterpoint to that is
well that is being paid for by
um you know the uh tv license fee which
everyone in the uk has to pay
so there's a tax you know so so this is
not you know
bbc is pretty good um but you gotta read
around
exactly you gotta read around because
which is sad you know
it's you know pretty good doesn't mean
you can just trust every single thing
you're gonna read from
from them or from anybody so you know
when it comes to sources
they have a lot of dry articles that's a
good thing right when you read the news
and it's like you know donald trump said
today that he was planning on putting
tariffs on this country
joe biden responded you know blah blah
blah and that's just it's just that
you're like okay that's that's probably
just you know good right it's when they
start talking about
the far right and the you know yeah it's
like opinion possibilities
right the definition here's the
important point about the times v
sullivan thing
that project veritas has just won and
may set precedent for years to come
they you i'm sure you're familiar
they're showing the new york times you
heard about that yes
well they got past the motion to dismiss
which is huge i think james said
only eight times in the past you know 80
years or whatever has the has a motion
to
miss been have people gotten past that
and what the judge basically said is
that
you know well hold on the new york times
said these statements about project
veritas being deceptive
are unverifiable opinion
and thus are not actionable and so the
judge responded okay well
if that was the case then i guess a
fact-based news article or at least one
purporting to be would have to inform
its readers this is an opinion
not a certain opinion as a fact in which
case i guess he's basically saying
if you say this article i'm about to
read to you is 100
fact ian is a deceiver and a liar then
the assumption is i'm saying statements
of fact in a newspaper
yeah i i just think when we get to the
supreme court i i i i take the point
that the case law is trying i think the
judges are trying to get a little bit
more
nuance on this and when it gets to the
supreme court that i think it's probably
going to be you know eight to one
uh in favor in the new york times
because i think the judiciary
and and i really i ultimately i think
it's the right course uh
that they should be allowed the maximum
no that maximal speech
uh for all its costs lies included uh
is advantageous over um
not so much restricted speech but the
chilling of speech i think that is the
great
concern in jurisprudence and really
foundational actually to the united
states i mean and you look at how
the contrast in english defamation law
for example which is why you know
we were talking earlier i think why we
have the qatar world cup it's a very
good case to be made for that that the
lawyers the sunday times
uh didn't report as early as they could
have on the the bribery
um and you know certainly that that
it's interesting for example how much uh
american
journalists will get um letters from
you know english london pr or legal
firms saying
this is uh highly defamatory take it
down no
no no i know that's the you know who
would maybe agree with that is and it's
a lot of lies
and they get well i i don't think it is
i think when you're talking about
russian organized crime bosses who like
to kill people and it doesn't get
reported in the british media because
they have a lot of money or take you to
court that's good thing that
you know i'm writing about that i
couldn't do that in england that matters
that stuff
the problem then is that they literally
just make things up activists are
dominating these newsrooms and when
you know the the idea works when you
have a newsroom that's filled with
people of good moral standing
you'll have a few bad people trying to
lie but when activists take over a
newsroom like they did in the new york
times and they did
several employees have already resigned
or been forced out or written letters
about it
then there's gonna be like awesome now
we're gonna use times v sullivan to say
whatever we want about whoever we want
there's nothing they can do about it
but then they literally come out and say
the new york times said in their defense
our our news article which is purporting
to be statements of fact are actually
unverifiable opinion
and the average reader doesn't know that
you know i i guess i
i have more confidence in the the
average reader in terms of being more
discriminate i think
certainly again this this generational
ship when you look at you know
your viewership uh the hill saga and
jetty and crystal ball show
um you know these new form media places
are just growing exponentially
and you know you got to think that that
that some of these people are um
even if they're not necessarily
abandoning you know they're still
reading the new york times
uh they're reading around more or
viewing around more right and and so
you know i do think again at some point
you're always going to have those people
who want to hear what they want to hear
um but you're also going to have i think
a lot of people who
um get slightly frustrated with limited
time right they want to be informed you
know
investigative journalism that really
stands up is still the best way to
generate traffic
you know i'm fairly optimistic so i
probably i would say i agree with you
more than i don't i may be concerned
about a lot of these lies but
with sub stack with the sheer panic
we're seeing in the faces of these
corporate media outlets they're they're
freaking out
glenn greenwald just announced that he's
going to be taking on freelance writers
for his sub stack which is like just the
other day i was saying like man we gotta
we gotta see matt tabi glen greenwald
start bringing out people grow their
organizations
use the sub stack model to create new
news outlets he's doing it
what is sub stack it's it's just
basically like uh
like a like patreon for writing i guess
you can set up an account
tell people you know x dollars a month
and you can see my articles oh cool and
then glenn writes his articles as he's
always done
and people will toss them a couple bucks
a month to do so
i mean think about it you get ten
thousand um
true fans just ten thousand at ten bucks
a month
you're making a million dollars sub
stack takes a cut right now
i think sub stack is actually taking
most of the money
but they're writing huge advance checks
to basically kick start the careers
or or should say the the you know right
now there's some people who have like a
thousand or two thousand paying
subscribers
it's it's enough for maybe a younger
person someone who's older with a family
like especially a prominent writer is to
be like i'm going to be losing a lot of
money cutting my salary in half to do
this
so so you know they're announcing okay
we'll give you half a million dollars
for two years which is
huge and then after the two years is up
we revert the subscriptions back to you
and we get you know 10
or something interesting yeah and we do
see with you know with like twitchy
with gaming the degree to which people
are
even not not for influence which is i
think quite refreshing
but um and the same is true with sub
stack uh or at least with patreon i'm
not sure if it is true with sub stack
are willing to you know pay more for
that extra tier right to me
engage maybe it's a phone call you know
a video conference whatever
and it's it's not kind of editorial
pressure right that a company that is
you know buying millions of dollars of
ads um you know so there's that kind of
fresher investment portfolio that goes
with that and it's also interesting you
think about like matt iglesias right
from vox
vox was that kind of fresh startup and
he sort of left there and is doing his
subs
so there's this revolutionary uh dynamic
in media which
you know you've got to think is positive
this is a great thing um
because what a lot of these people are
realizing too some of these people have
300 400
000 followers on twitter and now they're
seeing
someone with only a thousand fans but
real fans paying 10 bucks a month
these people are now making a six-figure
salary and these people on twitter are
like wait
you're getting paid i got hundreds of
thousands of people i'm not getting any
money
right you got some people who work you
know they got hundreds of thousands of
followers
they go and work for cnn what are they
getting paid
a six-figure salary probably decent and
they're thinking like if i got
10 000 of my followers to pay 10 bucks a
month i'd be a millionaire
so they're going to start leaving these
companies they're going to cut off that
editorial oversight
and this guy who says this is what cnn
does we propagandize to help trump to
help you know
to make trump lose people are going to
leave they're not going to be involved
in that anymore and they're going to be
back i can write about whatever i want
and then they're going to start well a
lot of people will just write tribal
garbage because
you know a lot of people are just tribal
garbage but a lot of people are going to
write what they feel like writing
and i think this is good because it's
going to diversify opinions in a lot of
ways and then we're going to watch these
these news outlets just
yep and then they will be connected
through the confettiverse
confettiverse yeah why are we calling it
the confetti we're gonna confederate
basically so that we all inter-operate
right that's a very poor choice
well rather than it being a fetiverse
where it's top down
i don't know whatever call whatever we
want i think meta nets another
federation
the federation of uh like federation is
cool basically star trek right
confederacy in this game these companies
that are like confederate you know like
siphoning off the value of their workers
that are like come work for me and i'll
i'll recoup the ad revenue and then pay
you a salary that's going away i get it
i get it
but just for branding let's try and go
like star trek
you know the federation of planets
united federation of planets yeah
instead of the confederacy you know i
don't even know what's the difference
between a confederacy and a federacy
i think a confederacy is within a
um that a unitary
political structure at the top where the
federation is
um many different so the confederacy has
one you know president
uh and the federation is the sort of
council but i may have got that totally
wrong so maybe shut up i'll just shut up
the other way around the way around
actually okay yeah the fat like like the
federal
government you know but i don't know i
don't know i think my honestly might be
like that you're probably right
flammable and inflammable pond just
means with so with federation
that's flammable and inflammable beware
the same thing
yeah yeah there's there you go it's just
branding it's just brand new
it's like hey you want to you want to be
like the sci-fi future of awesome or do
you want to sound like those guys now
yeah so we just had an exercise there in
being being wary of a british accent
being the deliverer
intellectual analysis we've been working
on this fetiverse
project and i mean i think writers are
going that way too it's it's not only
going to be video makers it's going to
be all these oh
that's out of business yeah exactly so
listen to this
you write for sub stack you know these
people are making six figures and it's
fantastic but substance wants to take 10
the hosting cost of an article is
nothing
the hosting cost of a video is
substantial substantial so
you got look if if you're somebody who
makes videos for youtube
i understand why you want to use youtube
because uploading videos this live
stream my friends those those of you who
are listening to this we're live right
now on youtube
this would be so insanely expensive you
know 32
000 plus viewers you know we sometimes
reach 50 or even 60 we've had
over 100 some episodes i've calculated
those costs with with business to
business companies in the past
and that's going to cost you thousands
of dollars per minute or hour like it's
just
gnarly the data cost because you've got
to understand this the transmission
of a high definition broadcast two
megabits per second
going up and then going out to you know
40 000 people so multiply your your
bandwidth and like whoo
so you use youtube youtube subsidizes
these costs sub stack though
you write an article it's text it's like
it's there's no data at all basically
it's a tiny file
so what are you paying subtech 10
percent for so we want to make this
project
we're actually working on ian
spearheading it where
you can download this open source
package for your own website that turns
your website into your own
privately owned subscription service
platform just like a regular website
with a membership option
but it's like one click and boom you're
done that also networks you with all the
other websites that use the same
software so effectively
you won't need to go to sub stack or
patreon or any of these other
subscription services
because now someone could own their own
website and keep 100 percent of the
revenue that comes in with open source
free software right that's the mission
that sounds pretty cool
yeah you know we'll we'll we'll see it's
it's i i don't i wouldn't say it's too
ambitious
no it's not particularly common no it's
going to happen regardless we're just
helping it along
and this is going to help decentralize
the news media
it's going to help decentralize
commentary it's going to protect people
who would have their income destroyed by
a subscription service that says well
you're offensive and we don't want you
on our platform
all right well that's your own website
you still got to deal with your hosting
provider you know
who's running your servers where you get
your domain names from you still got to
follow their rules there's still some
payment processor i think in the future
we'll be able to find workarounds for
ever
all of those things and one open source
package that covers everything
yeah man simplicity and control are good
combinations first yeah they're all
perspective
then people will be allowed to express
themselves honestly and without
uh manipulation and uh without fear of
getting canceled
that's the plan let's jump to this next
story though because uh you know we went
a little long on that one but i thought
it was worth talking about because the
media is trash
yeah and i forced my daily shout out to
the fetaverse
rock and roll yeah i mean the fat of us
is a ton of like mastodon it's
particularly lefty
but it's a protocol that you can't do
anything about it check this out
you guys have heard their riots going on
we got the story from
abc 5 eyewitness news sources say
washington county attorney's office
expected to charge officer in brooklyn
center shooting on wednesday
so this is this woman her name is kim
potter
the case was sent to the washington
county attorney's office to avoid a
conflict of interest with the hennepin
county attorney's office
which works closely with brooklyn
center's police on criminal cases
the extent of the charges will be
learned tomorrow brooklyn center police
released body camera
video that shows officer potter shooting
and killing 20-year-old dante wright
sunday afternoon
brooklyn center's former police chief
tim gannon he police chief resigned
today this is nuts the city's
like the whole area is just falling
apart stadium believed potter
accidentally discharged her weapon
believing she was using her taser not
her gun potter and ganon resigned from
brooklyn center police department on
tuesday and you know what
i can't speak too much for this this
officer kim potter
she shot somebody cops you look i don't
care who you are you're responsible for
what comes out of your gun
that's just basic you know gun
responsibility
i understand it wasn't intentional or at
least that's what they're claiming we'll
see how this investigation goes
but for the police chief to resign i'm
like i'm giving applauses
yeah bravo i think every single cop in
the in the twin cities area and suburbs
they should all
right now turn in their badges and walk
away why
they should all resign all of them right
now right at once
you must be joking i am not i mean it
why do you think they should resign
well because these leftists have
demanded the police be abolished
i think the police say okay i think yes
absolutely
police you're not wanted here the
activists have said so the logic oozes
out
you know what the issue is where are the
regular people standing up
and saying no don't do this when the
police
were under threat last year when the
riots were sweeping across the
the state in these cities the police
were scapegoated were insulted berated
over over the actions of a few i'm not a
big fan of the place as a whole i think
they need reform
but i understand individuals many of
these cops they're good people they're
not trying to get in between and get in
politics
there's some real risks with trying to
neutrally enforce the law when you've
got some people saying yeah do one thing
some people saying
you gotta do the other thing and then
accidents happen some cops are really
bad people they should be accountable
but we need police we a civil society
requires police to be able to make
arrests
this guy dante right he was wanted now
they're reporting an aggravated robbery
so that was his warrant
like okay that's a legit crime don't
resist
if the cops are arresting you you fight
it in court and he decided to jump in
his car and and scuffled out with the
cops
these cops are being treated like trash
so i say
they show all of these people they they
they tell the people of
you know where they live if you won't if
people here won't stand up for us
if people here aren't willing to do what
it takes to empower the police to
protect them
they must not want them there so here's
what i see the loudest the squeaky wheel
are those who riot
saying abolish the police rashida to
labe what did she say no more policing
no more get him out of there and the
cops stand to fight and say we will not
stand for this
but i mean we've been seeing even
conservatives throw blue lives matter
flags in the dirt and step on it
because the cops were enforcing these
unconstitutional lockdowns
right now what we need are the regular
people to prove
that they actually want the police if
they won't do that
then as far as i'm concerned the vote's
in but how do they do that
stand up go outside protest hold big
rallies and say we support our police
they won't do it though they will not do
it says to me
they don't care i really really think
most people don't care about any of this
and so my point is what do you think
will happen if the police say
blue flu we're all sick it will take 10
seconds
for the people of these cities to call
the officers personally and say please i
beg of you come back or the department
will hire a bunch of scabs
and the crap officers will come in and
do really crappy jobs and be violent and
even worse
what do you think is happening already
is that all the good cops i should say
all of them but many of the good cops
quit
last year in seattle in portland and
minneapolis we saw across the country in
exodus
the good cops were the ones saying i
will not be abused
i will not be a party to this and i will
not stand by while the d.a the
prosecutors allow rioters to destroy
these cities and they do nothing when we
arrest them
i'm done you got it they voted for this
they had an election
and they voted for this so at this point
i'm dumbfounded as the police who think
they're going to be accept what they're
doing is acceptable in a community that
absolutely despises them
i i also think that we have to be
careful here though because i think the
very best cops
stay for all this in in the same way
that some of the very best
you know members of the military or
whatever professional branch under
pressure nurses
um you know that they a sense of duty
which is kind of antithetical to
to some of the contemporary you know
discourse but but
people who truly believe that the
kinship of service
uh of going out there and still doing it
um
whether for religious reasons just moral
reasons um
you know i i agree that at the political
level i agree with you
i'm surprised that frankly the
republican party hasn't been more
aggressive
in terms of saying hey look body cameras
zero sun game
let's get those body cameras everyone
right it's great good cops
love it great evidence okay what's the
worst that happens they get you know
locker room talk
is caught in the car yeah but most of us
in society think if this okay
fine um but but at the level of
you know again rashida sleep right who
is held up
as uh by the media will say on one hand
well she doesn't represent the
democratic party on the other hand
this great sort of new visionary for the
party you know having the cake and
eating it
yeah you know this is pretty wacko stuff
uh
yeah the big issue is that these cops
will arrest these extremists
the rioters the looters and then the da
will say you're free to go
and release them without charge a bunch
of felony charges in portland got
dropped
and these cops are like well i'll just
keep doing the same thing and expect a
different outcome or i guess some of the
cops are probably like well i know
they're not going to jail but i sure
love bashing skulls
i can't i can't imagine so let me let me
slow down for a minute
state police who were brought in to
portland retreated saying
we arrest these people and the
prosecutors let them go we're done we're
not doing this anymore and i'm like
thank you that makes sense and then what
happened was
the dhs deputized state
police as federal law enforcement so
that when the state police arrested
someone the federal prosecutors could
step in
brilliant no escalation of force no
military coming in
and now these people were getting
prosecuted and you know it happened many
of the activists ran scared
they sorry i shouldn't i shouldn't call
them activists activists are great
these are extremists and terrorists they
started panicking writing blogs saying
the fbi showed up to my house the fbi
showed to my friend's house
this is not a game anymore the cost
for the extremists when they burn down
buildings is much
too low they're risking people's lives
there was active gunfire the other night
in in the minneapolis area
and the cost for these people is zero in
portland what happened to those guys who
fired hundreds of rounds
from rifles into an suv with two
teenagers killing them
the cost was nothing and these
extremists know it
they can go out they can burn things
down and nothing will happen well the
cost is
cop will jam you up but don't worry your
good buddy and the da will cut you loose
in two seconds and the cops will just
shrug
the cops need to be like i'm not going
to do it you do it
i also think one of the great tragic you
know
ironies here is that you know the black
lives matter movement
um you know trying to address you know
real issues
at the same time the utter unwillingness
to face up to the fact that we talk
about what do police officers do for
example
we've seen it right in the in the summer
crime waves baltimore uh chicago
it was a baltimore sun economist who
wrote a great piece on this i think you
know
a year ago the cops stop
doing their job right that they said i
am not going to entertain this personal
risk to me this liability vilification
in case i get it wrong and what is the
consequence of that
well in some of these areas in many of
these cities where
the predominant homicide issue is young
black men killing other young black men
more young black men die and and as a
society
then when we have rashida talib saying
this does she seriously care
about the intro she's talking about the
facts would suggest i would say
forensically
that she does not uh and and making that
case
you know you would think there would be
opportunities here for for
you know young republican mayors
independent
mayors to run and say hey we are going
to have accountability on the part of
the police again that body camera issue
um you know very well funded uh internal
affairs departments but at the same time
we're going to go out and try and stop
criminality and there's a racism in the
sense that people wouldn't want that
you know of course most people want to
be able to live their lives in safety
you take a look at what the left tends
to care about what the media tends to
report on
and it's getting just so obvious it's
mind-numbing
you know there was there's a viral tweet
i can't remember where it's from so
forgive me but they were saying
something like
the media actually you know
sorts through all the different news
stories trying to find the one story
that would cause the most hate and
division
that will get them traffic and get them
clicks to their website and that fuels
all of this
then you end up with a bunch of young
people who are deranged i mean there's a
video
i don't know if you guys have seen it
where it's this guy with no shirt on on
the ground just screaming and
crying that glove's better like
at the top of his lungs and i'm like
this man needs to turn twitter off
turn off the tv like go see a movie go
go watch burns of birds of prey
maybe he'll like that one okay and then
he'll just like calm down
dude the world is not ending things are
not worse than they've ever been
these people have genuinely gone nuts
then from this
you get people pandering to them the
politicians people like rashid to life
step
up and they say something like i'm going
to say something mindless and insane and
hope that someone votes for me because
of it
and then the whole system just what is
this i'm looking at this telev quote
that police should be abolished because
this is from daily mail because force is
intentionally racist this is the quote
intentionally racist and cannot be
reformed
force is intentionally racist and cannot
be reformed
force is like a scientific phrase it's
not
it's it's it's a mechanical function
well so so rashida toleb in response to
all of this
tweeted it wasn't an accident policing
in our country is inherently
unintentionally racist
dante wright was met with aggression and
violence i am done with those who
condone government-funded murder
no more policing incarceration and
militarization it can't
be reform okay let's take two seconds
here
first it was initially reported that
this guy dante
wright was wanted on a misdemeanor gun
charge
and apparently he got stopped they found
out he had a gun he fled
now when i heard that i was like sounds
to me like his only crime was the
non-crime of
enjoying a second amendment rights if
that's the case
then this is absolutely wrong however
even if it was
in my opinion an unjustified and
unconstitutional act you don't
resist the police when they come to
arrest you
you you you have the privilege of a
trial to defend yourself and actually
fight for others in the process because
the precedent set by your cases
could help others in the future instead
he fought with the cops he dove into the
car
they knew he's on a weapons charge he
had a ruger 45 he ended up getting shot
and killed and it's a tragic story i
wish it didn't happen but come on
the cops need to be able to make arrests
the cops don't know who this guy is or
what his story is
they don't know if he's a good guy a bad
guy all they know is we got a warrant
but now it turns out
it was it was an aggravated robbery
charge so this warrant was actually like
this guy
strangled a woman and demanded 800 from
her at gunpoint
okay hold on a minute it's a little
different yeah he probably should be
arrested for that
and he resisted and tried running away
we have the story actually from the new
york post
they say dante wright had an open
warrant related to an
armed robbery against him when he was
shot dead sunday
right 20 and another man had been
charged with first degree attempted
aggravated robbery in december 2019
for allegedly trying to steal 820 from a
woman at gunpoint
according to henneman county district
court documents the pair had crashed at
the victim's home
crashed the victim's home in the city of
ossio after attending a party there
then demanded money the next morning
while flashing a gun authorities said in
court papers
give me the effing money i'm not playing
around right told the woman
according to prosecutors the victim
refused and began screaming for both men
to leave
records show give me the money and we
will leave right allegedly told her give
me the money and we'll go
the two men eventually left the home
without any dough according documents
wright was later arrested in the case
and released in a hundred thousand
dollars bail
but he violated his bail conditions in
july when he failed to stay in touch
with his court monitor
the paper said according to the daily
mail he was also in possession of a gun
at some point after his arrest for the
robbery which was also in violation of
the condition of his bail release
so apparently that case was actually
derivative
of the fact that he tried shaking
someone he tried an armed robbery
now rasheeda toled here's what she you
got to think about what she's saying now
in this context
this the sheer absurdity of this it
wasn't an
accident it clearly was an accident i i
tweeted
the cop should go to jail because two
things you're responsible for what comes
out of your gun
this was a negligent shooting right it
wasn't an accident
she was reaching for a weapon she was
intending to cause harm she wasn't
intending to kill him not murder but
negligence
also these police in the area need to at
this
how do they not realize the
ramifications the political consequences
of what they're doing
defending what's going on right now if
they genuinely believe
chauvin was just doing his job and these
cops are being unjustly prosecuted
morale is low
shouldn't they stand up for themselves
so i i have very little empathy if any
for people who are like i know they're
going to throw someone under the bus but
i'm going to say nothing
and then i'll be fine even after saying
that i still recognize the shooting was
not intentional
i still recognize this guy broke the
line was resisting i still recognize
the altercation could have been avoided
it was the actions of the individual
being pulled over
cops got to do their job and rasheed to
lab is saying
no more policing okay
no more policing right and and and you
know i think as well that
the circumstances that you identify
there certainly will be used
at the trial right if if charges if they
try and up charge beyond
uh negligent manslaughter right because
that speaks to
the circumstances that police officers
face them in right when the dispatcher
says go to this call
it's going to be you know proceed with
caution armed dangerous
this you know um reasonable suspicion to
believe
that actually probable cause in this
case that there this person is capable
of
violence and the officer would say okay
i have fear that's why i didn't think
properly
but i do think the broader point in
terms of the political discourse
you know as you suggest has been heavily
weighted i just i guess i'm more
i do think there is again this this sort
of silent majority
yes needs to be more uh visible both at
a political level and at a populist
level
um but again it's to say it's the silent
trump voter again right that most people
think this is totally choose profanity
you know profanity of choice um
it it is interesting though that we
don't hold
rasheed slay in the same kind of
disdain that we would if you know
donald trump you know some of the things
that president trump has tweeted for
example
uh you know this is really this is
kind of ufo you know outer space stuff
except ufos are actually serious you
know you know i will say
in terms of you know saying the cops
should be arrested my bigger
issue that that infuriates me with
everything
is that there are people who will
privately say to you
i'm so upset with what's going on and
then you're like all right will you
stand up with me
oh no no heavens no i won't take any
risk
it's like you know i've always uh i've
always respected the idea
that you know back in the day in these
wars the leader would be on a horse and
he would charge in
with his men and lead them into battle
now you've got people who are like yes
look at all these problems
oh i'm not going to say anything i don't
want to get cancelled
you do it for me so when i see these
cops sitting back
while other cops are being demonized and
villainized thinking like
meh what do i care i won't speak up i
won't stand up i won't resign i won't
protest this
i'm like okay if you won't defend others
who have been put in these positions i'm
not going to defend you
i think this lady should go to prison i
think she should i hope the system comes
for her
for all it's worth chauvin as we are now
learning
it's not so so so clear-cut exactly what
happened
and why floyd lost his life and they're
trying to charge him with second-degree
murder
now manslaughter might make sense
there's an argument for there and in
fact the state may have actually
convinced the jury of that we'll see
what happens the defense is arguing
tomorrow and thursday and then i think
they're off friday and then double
the deliberations begin but murder two
and three are insane
the fact of the system charged him with
this in the first place was nuts he's
probably going to get quite on that
charge there's probably going to be
riots
keith ellison right right hyper
political
exactly looking for his own future
aspirations at the expense of the law
but i i what bothers me is that there
were a lot of good cops
who walked when this went down and they
said if you're going to play this game
i won't be a part of it and i applaud
those cops because those are the good
cops
some of them are probably actually bad
people but they're willing to stand up
at least for themselves
this cop just seems like another one of
these people who thinks that as the
world is burning down around them they
can say nothing and do nothing and
they'll be fine it won't come for them
i talk about this all the time with like
the wokeness the critical race theory
stuff
where people are like i know it's bad
but as long as i keep my head down i'll
be fine you know you won't
if if this really is as bad as people
think it is eventually it will come for
you and there's no escaping it your best
chance now is to speak up
otherwise there will be no one left to
speak up for you now she's been involved
in this
the political system is dominated by
these activists the city manager got
fired for calling for due process and
i'm just like
well i mean you knew this was going to
happen you knew it's what they called
for last year you knew they
literally voted to abolish the police
one town over 10 miles from you why
should i have
why should i have sympathy for this a
lot a lot of people i know
a lot of good people i've talked to in
the minnesota minneapolis area
have straight up said yeah we're moving
we're leaving right we won't be a part
of this
we won't let our tax dollars fund this
and then a bunch of people just shrugged
it off and said oh whatever
okay well now you get to be chauvin but
i do think you know again
this stuff does hit a i i agree with you
in the broad
need to identify to call out that you
know
the council culture you know the the
fake wokery whatever
um but at the point of paying taxes as
you suggest i think a lot of people like
enough because the especially on these
policing matters
it's not simply the matter of taxes it's
taxes for
you know an exigent interest right
protection of self and family
and when you combine those two factors
you know i do think we will
i mean this is just going to be a
developing trend it's also i think at
the political
level ultimately why the rashida delay
crowd
uh is going to lose ultimately ultimate
ultimately yeah sure i mean look
president trump really
nearly won right and i i i do agree with
you i do
that they'll end up losing yeah it just
the problem is
it's not going to happen until there's
widespread violence and destruction on a
scale that we will regret
i'm sure many people are upset about
what happened last year with the george
floyd riots
regret is a hard word to use because it
caught everyone off guard
and now we're looking back at like how
do we stop this
anger you know for the people who rioted
and looted
now we have an option we have a chance
are we going to stand up and do
something before it's too late
apparently the answer is no
obviously you know we'll talk about this
people who are watching the show
understand what's going on
but too many regular people have been
ignoring this the cops in brooklyn
center
thought they would be allowed to get
past the lunatic woke outrage mob
they thought they would be safe are you
kidding me your
your fellow officers are going down in
flames and being sacrificed at the woke
altar
and you did nothing you said nothing you
said i'll be fine well now you're not
fine
so that that these cops have a chance if
they all resign today
by tomorrow the police would be totally
funded
they'd have better training much of
these problems would be solved they'd be
better equipped they'd be safer
the problem isn't that police have too
much funding is that they have too
little funding we are asking people and
these activists don't remember this
these cops are human beings
to go into situations where people want
to kill them we've seen the videos
they're scary videos
where someone reaches into their car we
saw the guy in in in wisconsin in
kenosha
when he was going to his car he grabbed
the knife and the cop shot him
and then they riot in that city
apparently that cop is back on duty
actually i don't think he did anything
wrong like someone grabbed a knife
this guy had assaulted a woman these
people don't realize this about these
cops
that they're not vicious and depraved
murderers and many of these people are
psychologically damaged after being
involved in these shootings i mean this
woman
i really do believe she accidentally
shot this guy dante she went holy yes i
just shot him i don't think she meant to
do that
i'm sure she's been crying non-stop
mentally just
fractured because of this so with
respect i'm not trying to be mean
if the police right now said to the
people we have been dealing with riots
non-stop for a year
we have begged for your support and
instead all we have gotten was
defunded insulted demoralized abolished
and scapegoated
our city is all yours i think the moral
way to do it though would be to give
you know a period of notice 30 days
because
because then you can balance because
it's actually much better because then
at least you know when you do it say hey
we it's not this is now
the political responsibility right the
crimes that happen in that window
of absent policing uh but but you know i
also think as well the delusion right
that
that anyone who says like rashida to
leave you know policing get rid of it
incarceration doesn't work great you
know
these are not people who have been
exposed to criminality right right
police officers
you know that anyone who knows anyone
who's been to prison uh
i think would come out and say there are
a lot of people in there who
had really a bad start to life uh could
they have been diverted
um there are also a lot of people who
are really not nice people
yeah and when we're talking not nice
we're like you know really not nice and
and and so police officers dealing with
that every day
um one of the things i found interesting
is like
in some ways british humor is very
similar to like american police humor
it's very dark and i think part of the
transit and it does british human
doesn't sometimes translate in the
united states and i think part of the
reason police officers
or a big reason is that you know you're
just dealing
every day with tragic circumstances
you're doing a lot of good but you're
also dealing with
really unpleasant people yeah and that
takes a toll
did you hear about the the cash bail
thing in new york where they're
they they want to get rid of it or they
get they get they got rid of it i'm
sorry
i i i actually didn't no so uh earlier
in the year like last year
there was this bill where they said
basically if you're arrested for a
certain you know certain non-violence oh
mr mean at the level
yeah right you will be auto released
order right so no bail because
and here's the challenge man i don't
like the idea of charging people money
to get out of jail right wait
because innocent until proven guilty
it's better that the guilty escape and
you know innocent suffer
all that stuff blackstone's formulation
but there was apparently one guy
who got arrested several times he kept
getting released and
apparently in a quote he was laughing he
was like y'all caught me doing it and
let me go
right it's like we have to it's the
constitution but
some people are bad people and we know
it right and it's and
it's and it's tough to deal with these
people while maintaining constitutional
rights
but there is an interesting issue here
as well that you know one of the
controversies
for some is that the police the judges
are elected here right at
a local level yeah and and you know i do
think there can be a cost to that that
that
the reflex can be more punitive
sometimes for certain crimes but the
benefit
is that you can avoid a situation for
example uh
that exists uh in much of europe
certainly in the uk
in britain where um the cops are
arresting people and they've got a rap
sheet that is just pages and pages long
and the judges are still sort of you
know 90 day community service centers
and how that not simply the the and
the immorality of that in a democratic
society
um but also how that corrodes the public
trust which the
public ultimately in a democracy must be
the guardians right or must be the
masters
how they have no essentially you know
the judiciary accepted
separate to the political um branch but
there's no input right that they just
simply see
exactly and people eventually just like
they lose faith
this is this is the system the system is
supposed to work because of judges
because a judge can look at a person and
say
you committed you're accused of this
crime what say you if the person says
your honor i beg of you i have to work
my job and be with my kids i will be in
court and the judge can be like okay
let's
let's set some conditions that aren't
cash because you can't afford it
where we can ensure you will come to
work how about house arrest
but with a provision for you go to work
right instead
i've seen these videos where the judge
is like your bailout set is a thousand
dollars
your honor i i watch this video it was
maddening the guy's like
your honor please please i have to go to
i have to be with my family i have to
work my job i'll lose my job if i'm in
jail he goes i said one thousand dollars
bang
and i'm like that to me doesn't work
because now maybe in this instance the
guy actually was a bad dude who was just
trying to pull a fast one
but then you have the inverse where you
just mentioned in new york it's like
your honor we arrested this guy all
right i understand the cashless bail
thing but like
here's his rap sheet he's been convicted
of seven crimes in the past
can we at least hold this guy no free to
go right
the judge is supposed to be interpreting
this better and i feel like too often we
don't get it we get
but maybe maybe maybe it's because
there's no real simple answer maybe
we're going to learn about the harsh
cases and the lacks cases maybe the
reality is
you know there's good judges in the
middle who find that middle ground and
then and all this right the same thing
in san francisco right that that they
were not arresting
you know certain things would be treated
misdemeanor stealing from a car you know
anonymous right right right and and
actually that's a much better example
you look at um
you know the the kind of woke element
the left right and it's easy
it's much easier to become part of the
work crowd and and wave
than it is to be like you know kind of
larry david out of kirby enthusiasm and
be like
you know like it's okay for them right
because they can go to the apartment
building that has a concierge and an
underground garage
but that small business owner or that
you know person who doesn't have you
know has to park their car on the street
that working class lower income person
they're the ones who are suffering the
most
it's not the people who are pushing this
the most but again i just think there is
a political opportunity here
that that uh we have to believe will be
taken advantage of well i'll tell you
who is
benefiting the most for one it's these
woke absurd politicians who
give us mindless platitudes and
ridiculous statements of no more police
that'll solve the problem
rasheed's life i agree let's get rid of
all the police right now how about we do
this
i think your idea was better give notice
let's have every cop in the country say
all right in 30 days we won't be working
you know why
because they're giving a heads up to the
criminals as well as the regular
citizens
they may as well announce the purge is
going to be a real thing
because all the criminals are going to
be like 30 days it's on baby
but i'll tell you who else is making
money these activists who claim to fight
for this stuff
they're cashing out i think a lot of
people have seen this story already
this black lives matter leader
apparently bought a
a massive mansion and a bunch of other
moderately priced and well actually
they're fairly expensive homes
so this bm this black lives matter lady
i guess she has what like three homes
that are like 400 to 500k
yeah and then one that's 1.4 million
yeah that's really good for a marxist
multiple properties kind of like you
know kind of like socialist bernie
sanders he's got what three homes
they're good for him i'm glad they've
been able to successfully capitalize on
socialism
so we have this story from the post
millennial black lives matter
i guess activist says story about
co-founders oh
black lives matter says this yeah story
about co-founders new multi-million
dollar home
are fueled by white supremacy i feel so
stupid
yeah that explains everything marxists
are allowed to have multiple properties
one that's 1.4 million dollars
they're allowed to that's normal for
marxists
landlords and property owners and you
know i mean
but it is in the kind of finest uh
in the your dashes and you have your
dockers actually uh
and you have your kind of access to the
you know the super highway
lane and there's nothing new to i mean
it's so obvious for what it is
um what i think what is i mean
there you have right a great example of
just the the absurdity of the kind of
work thing that that
that that is white supremacist that
everything is white supremacist
um and it does it is i mean literally we
are now living
in a you know kirby enthusiasm sketch
and and
and you know i actually saw it interview
it was a few years ago actually
larry david he was saying oh you know we
do have a lot of like conservative
viewers watch the show
and he's like it's kind of interesting
it's like yeah well because
reality is becoming that show you know
that it's that ridiculous
i mean i do it is interesting though
that you don't see
that many people on the kind of i guess
like bill maher does talk about this
a bit you know the absurdity of it but
it's kind of funny how
the crowd nervously laughs and the
guests
fee what's more interesting how these
high-profile guests
feel more of an impulse to be like well
bill you know
do you see that that lady who was that
lady she called gina carano a white
supremacist
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah former
senator yeah whoever she was she was
like well you know
she's heidi heitkamp right yeah yeah
yeah and bill maher
barely pushed back at all right like i
you know if someone said that here i'd
be like that's not true you're lying
right like no not we're not playing that
game that's not true
and it's funny because i say this about
enrique tario the
chairman of the proud boys literally a
black dude and they're like he's a white
supremacist i'm like no he's not no he's
he's
literally black and proud boys have
multi-racial you can criticize the proud
boys for a lot of things yeah just
criticize them for the things that are
true right
instead they lie and i'll you're not i'm
not going to play that game
bill maher should have come out and and
and and been much more
uh harsh to this woman he's like she's
not uh
is she really and then he goes well you
know definitions change
is that it i also think part of the
interesting thing here is you know it's
like you know this person's a nazi
whatever and i find
you know my british my american
grandfather was pacific marie
still around 96 which is great um and my
british grandfather was a raf bomber
command pilot
and so there's a lot of debate morally
right bombing german cities
but you know you study the nazis i
studied a lot of
about amateur hour but but read a lot
about them
it is kind of amusing with the american
like woke left talking nazi white
supremacy because they really haven't
how many of them have read minecap how
many of them have engaged seriously with
the literature to understand because it
is a profoundly
unpleasant ideology but but simplifying
it is not a good idea well hold on
i think many of them are in fact
familiar with it because as we know
james lindsay helen pluck rose and peter
pagosian
altered a portion of minecraft into
feminist ideology instead and it got
published in a scientific
journal so they've certainly read some
of the uh
i i think to be fair there's some heavy
criticism of that but the general idea
was
the intention and the targeting of
groups was what they ported over
and then someone accused them like all
they did was use the non-proper nouns
because the proper nouns were changed
and i'm like that's kind of the point
yeah like when he's like this group is
evil and we're the best and here's our
plan
and you just change the name of the
group that's kind of the point yeah so
these people that look they're they're
all about power
you know the the black lives matter
organization is basically saying we
don't pay her
she's not getting paid by us it's fake
news
um that's not the news the news is that
a prominent black lives matter activist
owns multiple homes and a very expensive
one
it's not i guess maybe some people infer
or assume
that she's making money from black lives
matter i didn't assume that i just
thought these people were hypocrites
claiming to fight for the common people
when actually they're just rich people
because i've seen it time and time again
al sharpton is the most ludicrous
personality
i mean it's quite astonishing actually
that you know you saw that it was a few
years ago that he needs his first class
you know c to go to speaking gigs and he
always turns up and then he disappears
i think michael brown's family were
talking about this how they felt they'd
been
and and it is just i mean the cost of it
is just
quite quite astonishing right that they
have we actually had an incident where i
live in washington and i don't want to
be too specific because it'll seem like
i'm using it
for my own but but a 19 year old black
guy was shot and killed
and no one the reaction
of people on the street who were very
much you know defund the police signs
yeah on that night uh was you know they
weren't
terribly interested as he was calling
for help and
and there's more to it that but but
there is a lot of um
again enter profanity of choice that is
really not just pathetic but
pretty outrageous in the sense that
these are people you know
people dying right we should want
solutions that mitigate that
you know you know what i've been kind of
pissed off about i hear this a lot from
a lot of conservatives
they'll say you know the black lives
matter people don't seem to care about
you know inner city youth or what's
going on in chicago and shy iraq
right how come they don't protest and
demand justice for the black lives in
chicago
who are victims of this crime all the
time i hear that a lot
now i've met some people who do focus on
that and they're smaller community
community activists but definitely the
high profile grifters make their quick
buck
off pushing this institutional racism
narrative i got a similar complaint
though
where the gun rights advocacy groups and
conservatives going into the same
neighborhoods
and providing legal defense for the
young black men whose only crime was
possession of a firearm right which the
second amendment says you're allowed to
do
it no it's a hugely good point you know
when when uh
well i'll just leave it at that without
you know getting into rehashing much of
all i would say
i don't know if he's been on the show if
not i mean obviously you pick your own
guess but show michael singleton
uh you know friend of mine uh does a you
know a black gun owner does a tv show
about it
uh engaged in you know some of this
stuff but um
you know so there are you know there's
actually though that's a very good point
of the judicial at the level of the big
well-funded conservative legal defense
these things representing religious
issues right
life that doesn't you know you're right
that there's there's that's a big gap
yeah there are a lot of uh particularly
young black men but even outside of that
there's a lot of people in this country
who get charged with illegal possession
of a firearm and that's it
now if they're committing a crime with
the gun okay fine i get it
you commit a crime you commit a crime um
i mean like if they're robbing somebody
if they're carjacking or doing something
like that or using the gun in the price
of a crime
if someone literally is like i would
like to bear arms you know the
constitution says shall not be infringed
i would like to see
you know the nra i'm not a big fan of
the nra but so i don't think they would
do anything but i'd like to see more
gun rights groups actually be like we're
going to go to washington dc we're going
to go to chicago we're going to go to la
we're going to go to compton we're going
to talk to these
we're going to find these young men
we're going to look at that that charge
sheet where it says illegal position of
a firearm and we're going to be like now
we're going to give you the legal
defense
because this is not right second
amendment is clear right these guys
didn't do anything wrong
it's it's it's similar to how i think
the left overlooks
violent crime in this neighborhood as
well it's not going to play well i mean
we got a viral video that's been going
on for a while of a woman holding her
baby getting shot and killed and then
lying on top of her baby to protect her
from these drive-by shooters and a lot
of conservatives are like where is black
lives matter where's the left
complaining about this and i'm like
it's a good point you know they they
they scream
when there's a cop and an accidental uh
you know an accident occurs or a tragedy
or in this instance negligence
but they're not screaming when you know
things things go bad in chicago they're
not screaming about the gang violence
it's just the cops now i get it there's
a fair point too
cops aren't positions of authority right
so i understand that
and then there's an argument for the
conservatives it's like some of these
guys who have these guns are actually in
gangs
and they have guns for not good reasons
but at the same time i'm like
honestly man i think we need to have
some some principle in the matter
if we're if we're four black lives we're
for the gang members as well
and if we're for gun ownership we're
four gang members as well
one of the things that i i'm surprised
and
you know there may be well i don't think
there is a good reason for it but
why uh we haven't seen more prosecutions
um
the fbi atf using rico statutes so
racketeering in the same way that they
do against russian organized crime
eastern european groups
um you know ms-13 whatever
where actually if you can build up your
evidentiary picture
you could have a pretty significant uh
judicial effect i think part of the
reason is that the um
you know the the some of the gangs
sometimes you know again you know the
young black men tend to be a part of
there's less um you know the economic
impact on society is lower uh as a term
in terms of criminal
finances and so the incentive for the
fbi is to go after higher value things
right but at the moral level and the
life level you know you would think that
would be something perhaps everyone
could get behind
of course i'm sure i'm totally
delusional about that but
you know they're being creative here
right it is
um surely something we need to do more
of
um you know because it's it's
pretty you know again those matches yeah
i think i got a good you know
overlapping nonprofit idea that i'm
gonna
see if i can you know get set up and i'm
you know so i've been talking to a few
people about this and it's quite
literally
to find young young men who are charged
with possession of a firearm and that's
it and then so i think chicago is a good
target for this because
i think it'll be maybe this could be a
position where you know a lot of the
black lives matter people not who are
not too democratic establishment where
they're just anti-gun for no reason
but a lot of these actual leftist
personalities who believe in black lives
matter i'll be like how about we get
these guys out of jail and
help them get their lives fixed because
they didn't do anything wrong they're
abiding they're enjoying their second
amendment rights
and then i think a lot of the gun owners
libertarians and even some conservatives
might be like all right we agree with
that as well
so i'm like maybe that's a that's a good
thing where we can be like hey we're
going to do this thing
don't yell at us because we're trying to
help and you know make make lives better
for everybody
and and and and i bet in a lot of those
cases right it's going to be
well we know it's it's that person
carrying that gun because they're in a
very high crime neighborhood and they
don't want to get robbed
i mean it's actually it is basic level
second amendment stuff right just and
i mean yeah it's like very rudimentary
just self-defense right right i want to
prank myself and that's true for a lot
of these guys right
because i i'm from i'm from chicago i
see guys who are like i'll be damned if
i'm going to be a victim of these people
these gangs i don't have anything to do
with it but
right they want to defend themselves i
will say it'd be really funny if we
start
you know we find people with standing
you get you get a young black man he's
got
you know a 1911 or something 45 and uh
he gets arrested and charged for that's
the only crime
the cops stop him you're under arrest
felony gun possession
we come in we say we're going to sue and
then it starts making its way up the
courts what are the democrats going to
do
what's their argument going to be we're
actually defending the rights of
minorities right and gunners at the same
time are they going to come in and say
that that black man should be in jail
oh i'd love to see him do that no i
think that black man should not be in
jail i think he has a right to defend
himself the same as everybody else
i heard the black panthers were out in
minnesota on sunday morning and they
were armed to the teeth and i say good
yeah right they're allowed to do it
absolutely nothing happened
and nothing happened well not from them
right other people went out later and
started trash and stuff it wasn't the
panthers right
they have a constitutional right to
protect themselves and to bear arms
and i think they're good american
citizens doing so right absolutely
totally agree
i'd like to see it happen we'll see
we'll see we'll see where we can go with
that yeah and again i
i i it's so instrumental right that that
is so
um talk about riots right in 2011 at
least in riots you know
as a gunner you can have a gun in your
home and you could at least have
relative confidence
relative um that you might be able to
protect your family
uh you know in 2011 in london there were
riots over three days and the cop
the police were totally overwhelmed
there was no
you know if you think about sort of
older people
uh people with health issues they it was
anarchy for them
people come into their homes you know
take stuff do whatever
and all that that only recourse with the
cops and more than that the people
doing it knew that right yeah here at
least there is a moment of pause
you would hope some people obviously
there isn't but but you know you're
going to walk in
and you know good night i'll i'll tell
you this
you know uh out in the middle of nowhere
and uh a little bit further west of
where we are
you see no trespassing sign yeah yeah
you definitely gonna obey that
trespassing sign
so like i've i've been out you know i
was thinking about this i was driving
through west virginia
and i look at all these houses and i'm
like you know
if if you if you even thought of robbing
this house
you're gonna die right like don't commit
crimes and so i mean people are
reasonable they're not gonna randomly
shoot a person that's in the property
but they're going to warn you and
they're going to be armed to the teeth
most of the people who live out here
they're armed because cops are few and
far between right
so you know it's interesting to me like
i was mentioning earlier
the cost for the activist of getting
caught rioting
is almost nothing their life will not be
harmed in any way
and it's really fascinating because
destroying property burning things down
and
literally causing harm to people are
very serious crimes
yet going back to this i hear these
stories of you know
you know 28 year old dad in chicago
who's scared of gang violence so he gets
an illegal gun
it's not it's not literally illegal
according to the constitution but the
state says it is
and that's his crime he gets to go to
prison he gets to get locked up and have
his life ruined
because he wants to protect himself from
gang violence in a city the city
that the police can't control that to me
is insane
then you have these rioters who go out
and destroy everything nothing happens
to them
it is interesting as well if we think
about the left's view on um
voter id laws right that is prohibitive
in terms of cost it
disproportionately affects minority
communities and yet
the same principle is not applied to
well you to buy a garden license to go
through that room
no that's okay that's something right it
is kind of interesting
yeah it's amazing voter id is racist
because it disenfranchises minorities
what about when menorahs want to go buy
a gun right is got gun ideas racist
right
that's a funny thing too about this
voting stuff when i think it was like
david hogg who said
buying a gun shouldn't be easier than
voting and i was like
are you suggesting that guns should be
mailed to everyone's home when they
don't ask for it right because mail and
bailouts got mailed out to everybody
even if you ask for it or not
could you imagine if you're like you
turn 18 and they mail you an ar-15
right i mean that'd be awesome
i'd be like great no that wouldn't be
awesome a lot of dumb people have
i mean think about that a gun and just
like laying us to someone's mailbox
no that's not a good idea we don't want
to do that like i get it go to go to a
shop
you know have the weapon properly
transferred be responsible take it
seriously follow the rules
get you know safety training and all
that stuff be responsible but that's
that's just it's an amazing gap in uh
how they actually view the rights of
minorities it's politically useful to be
like voter id is wrong
okay well let's get them all guns i
think the black panther should have guns
absolutely
i think these people these people in
chicago minnesota wherever have a right
to have guns
right where yet democrats where's black
lives matter on this one yeah
we can all fight for this the black
panthers showed up in richmond virginia
i think it was
when the 2a people were all protesting
and it's funny how the media tries
framing the second amendment guys as
like white supremacists and i'm like
they're taking selfies the black
panthers smiling
right like these people are all very
much like libertarian like
hey man you get your gun i got mine well
high five yeah
yeah i was in texas years ago and i saw
a bunch of you know guys
look kind of like militia guys standing
around at a trump rally with guns
and uh a guy showed up wearing a shirt i
think it was a black guns matter shirt
and it was a tall black dude with a
beard and a
some some you know probably a 556a15 of
some sort and he walked right up to
these right-wing trumpsters and they
shook hands started talking laughing
with each other
and it's because they had common
interests they probably didn't agree
politically on certain things
but they were very much pro-gun pro
liberty approach others rights and both
the white guy and the black guy
recognize each other as respecting the
rights
of the individual and that's what we
need more of yeah let's let's do this
we're gonna it's
this is a bit of a hard hard jump in
terms of a segway but i want to jump
into the story about ufos because i know
you're
you're a an enthusiast right right yeah
so we have the story
that uh uh it's actually been going
around for a little bit we've talked
about it quite a bit
pictures and videos show unidentified
flying objects moving above u.s navy
warships
this story was updated just recently the
other day and the reason it's
significant
military u.s naval ships national
security
installations are being spied on
essentially
something is flying above them
surveilling them perhaps
they're they're described as what tic
tacs well they're various forms uh tic
tacs
um triangles um
spheres encased in cubes and you know
all over the place you're saying
yeah yeah all over i mean the the ones
that we're looking at that that have hit
the news in recently
i'm sorry spheres encased in cubes yeah
that was the 2015
um uh 2015 theodore roosevelt
carrier strike group one of the pilots
described it looked like a sphere in
case nearly hit him
uh and so there are various forms that's
crazy yeah
and this stuff is not i mean this is
what you know i i'm
you know i do have a kind of eccentric
sort of you know british sense of humor
whatever
i'm relatively young as a journalist i
i tell people i'm covering this issue
because i feel
my sourcing on it is very good um it's
complementary to kind of writing about
russian and chinese military
activities research and development you
know it would be a very bad idea for me
to lean into this subject as i have if i
wasn't very very confident because
credibility wise
you become you know a a looney tune
right
yeah um so it is happening uh it's
happening near the
navy predominantly uh in their work up
areas off the east and west coast
uh the navy assesses that at least a
significant part of the reason it is
happening near the carriers and the
submarines
is because of the nuclear reactors and
weapons in some cases on those that
these things are attracted to it
that is top secret um because the the us
does not want china and russia to figure
out how that detection capability comes
about
wow because if they did figure that out
they could destroy our nuclear deterrent
forces yeah so what you're saying that
these weird flying things
somehow can detect our nuclear
capabilities yes yes and we don't want
russia and china to know how to detect
and that that's that's you know that's
classified that that assessment but it's
but it's not russia and china doing this
no it's not it's a hype we up you know
tim mcmillan who really i think is
probably the top journalist on this
at least from the u.s point of view in
the world the debrief um both
him and myself um you know
have said you know it's 99 sure we are
not simply because of
um you know as we understand it what
china and russia have in development and
they do have for example on hypersonic
hypersonic glide vehicles which are
going to be the new form of delivering
nuclear weapons um the russians
are at least in delivered platforms that
are deployed
more advanced than the united states
that's going to change soon
um but that's their top end stuff
this stuff is going hypersonic but from
stop to start
no jet fuel no no sonic boom no sonic
boom and some kick yeah
no sonic boom in most cases um the
propulsion vectors
uh the behavior patterns so you know the
top lines intelligently controlled
machines because of how they
interact uh happening since the end of
the second world war
and again this is just focusing on
military credible sources not you know
and i think a lot of these witnesses are
probably telling the truth but but you
know you want to go with police officers
people who have a lot to lose by saying
i saw this or radar data platforms
um intelligent control machines capable
trans medium travel underwater space um
you know through the air and again since
this
end of the second war really and we yeah
we had marco rubio i think recently he
said
that we like it's a serious threat we
should talk about because we don't know
who this is and they're flying over our
nationals
right and he talks about strategic
import he's talking about the nuclear
connection there right
uh and it you know marco ruby also wants
to run president again in the future
he's the chair of the senate and tower
actually now the vice chair of the
senate
senate intelligence committee um you
know
he knows he's seen that he knows this is
really a it's not china russia or us
something's going on um i'm going to
keep pushing this subject because it's
going to be good for my political career
and i think he thinks the public should
know more is it aliens
i think it probably is yes you think
it's probably alien i think it is
probably a
i am almost i'm highly confident it is
either aliens or extra dimensional or
something
or something crazy hey listen
that's a big thing to say right um you
know it's i i think that will be borne
out
uh in our lifetimes that it's it's it
really is something else
because if you again it's the sherlock
holmes thing right or you know
you eliminate the impossible all you're
left with it is not u.s china russia or
elon musk
and it's machinery and it's
intelligently controlled i don't know if
there are people in it or whatever
uh and it's been happening since the
second world war yeah so the manhattan
project right you could people like
google los alamos
um little green orbs you know
inter-dimensional dude that's oh yeah
you know extra dimension whatever
you know i i don't know and then that is
the sort of generous point that it's
something other
right yeah um but but that's that's the
basic that's why marco rubio is leaning
into this
because they know it's not the russians
and chinese and they don't and they you
know
so there's there's a conspiracy theory
that once we we actually dropped the
nukes
we basically sent a signal right so
those who could attacked
nuclear capabilities were like what are
these these
these you know creatures doing this is
insane high level of intellect
right technical proficiencies and they
understand how devastating these weapons
can be and then there's other
conspiracies that they've shut off our
nuclear capabilities in the past
yeah robert hastings uh who's become a
friend of mine he's the guy who wrote
the kind of bible on that ufo's and
nukes
not a terribly original title but the
sourcing is excellent
and yes they have and they've done it to
the russians what's interesting as well
is the
um you know the russians and chinese had
these experiences still
um you know nuclear platform sites as
um and uh the russians
um being russians in the cold winter
tried to shoot these things down
a couple of times and the pilots ended
up die um so oh
yeah yeah so there's a part i don't know
more than that that was actually came
out in a declassified
british military report i've heard it
from you know at least one other source
very good so there's a lot more to this
subject you ever see
stranger things uh no are you familiar
with the show
right so it's like there's the upside
down right when i when i think about
extra dimensional there's
there's one thing i've often wondered we
have
invisible means of data transmission
right
we use electromagnetic electromagnetic
waves of various uh frequencies
to send signals to other devices and i
often wondered i wonder if what is
invisible to us
is actually a physical phenomenon in
another dimension of sorts that we can't
perceive
and so we are actually just completely
ignorant of what we're doing
maybe on the other side so as we
broadcast a signal
you know like a five gigahertz signal to
us nothing happens we don't see anything
it's not ionizing radiation
but then maybe in this another dimension
or the upside down or whatever
it's actually like ripples like
pushing through water having a very
serious impact on something that might
be on the other side
yeah so real quick just when we talk
about extra dimensional i wonder if then
the reason they're detecting the nuclear
uh reactors and energy is because it's
having a physical reaction
in their dimension or whatever right
maybe you know
we don't know it's a wild wild crazy
thought to be
to be honest i have no idea there there
is you know and you can go back in in
in time you look at um you know there
was a situation with
one of the you know very top uh roman
generals
um i think finding the thracians uh
where
the testimony um of i forget the the
roman historian
um and it's actually on ufo sightings
you know wikipedia page but i went and
backtracked the sourcing is legitimate
uh describing what looks like ufo coming
in between two armies
um the behavior patterns of some of
these things are really interesting and
where they appear you know there's a
school connection point
um yep school in zimbabwe ariel school
in
1994 zimbabwe all the kids
eight-year-old nine-year-old kids
describing it
um some of them saying they saw a being
melbourne
1967 there's one in miami why are they
appearing at school sometimes those are
both saucer type
there's a lot to this it's hot it's easy
to go down uh the rabbit hole
uh but uh something very significant
is going on i'll tell you something
crazy um do you know about the
o'hare airport sighting yeah in 2006
yeah it was 2006 are you sure
uh pretty confident makes sense i
believe so uh
i worked at o'hare until 2006 and i had
friends who worked there
i worked in the term in the in the
terminal
not even not the terminal the um this
was in the united it was
it was above the gate right so where i
worked was just next to united terminal
so i worked for
american eagle airlines which is next to
american airlines and so a bunch of the
guys that uh i'd quit
and then this happened i think uh like
maybe like five or six months after
so i had friends who were still there
and they i and when this happened i was
immediately like yo yo what happened
what did you see
and a bunch of them said they saw it
they said that some
object came down through the clouds or
was was seen
floating in the sky for uh for a little
for a minute or two and then shot
straight up and punched a hole in the
clouds
and they were told it was a weather
phenomenon yeah now here's where it gets
crazy
one of my friends said they were driving
to work at the time or i i
they were driving on manheim road which
is outside of ohio i don't it's been a
long time mind you it's you know this is
what 15 years
they were on manheim road which is one
of the major roads
that goes up just next to o'hare airport
and they said
when this thing came down people stopped
their cars and got out and were staring
up at it
and i was told that people were taking
pictures early camera phones existed at
the time
and so i was like where's all that all
those photos at
now there was one photo that got
released the pilot was in the plane and
he
turned and took and this is grainy you
know crappy photo
but from what i heard and maybe it's
just exaggerations and
and hear saying it was wrong i had
someone tell me straight up they saw
people taking pictures of it
right where'd those pictures go no i we
didn't have the internet we didn't have
facebook the way we do so
maybe it's just sitting on these old you
know flip phones from 2006 that never
got put online i've heard the same thing
um interesting that the descriptions
there were a sorcerer you know it tends
to be now tic tacs triangles whether
that's multiple or
originating vectors right multiple um
things
but it's a very good point i also think
though people ask why do we not have
more photos now right with iphones such
good quality
you know whatever phone you have i think
that is going to be
these things when they're seen are
either willing to be seen
or want to be seen they are there are
photos of them
but there aren't as many as we might
expect i i think the issue is
let me put this away i once looked up at
the sky and the moon looked amazing and
i was just looking at the corona
and the color it was like a it was like
a blood moon with this massive corona
and it was a full moon and i was like
wow let me take a picture of this
i put my camera at it and it's a white
dot on the screen and i'm like i cannot
capture this moment on a phone
right i have seen weird things in the
sky before
that look like there's a tail coming off
and i'm like was that a comet or a
meteorite and i put my camera at it
and you lose all the definition and all
it is is a red dot with a with a grainy
blue background and i'm like damn i
can't take a picture of this
i think people overestimate the power of
cell phone cameras with
long range uh low resolution photographs
right so if you if i guess people are
expecting like the saucer to land in
their backyard and then they get a
higher resolution photo they're not
doing that they've never done that
so one thing though that hopefully you
obviously mentioned jeremy corbell's uh
the photos there were some other ones
that that i had that um
you know uh happened similar well
actually
you know slightly different time um one
thing that
myself and tim mcmillan reported on last
december uh
is a in december 2019 or they're about
um now that the pilots in the f-18s
right from the carrier groups have their
iphones
um they took one aircrew took a photo of
a triangle
uh which we've seen david mahler's
coming out the water
right um and that photo
i have not seen it i know it exists um
you know multiple sources and it's when
that photo comes out i think that will
be a really pretty pivotal moment
because it will be from
air crew there'll be like chain of
custody uh
and you know when you see that thing and
then when they match up the sense of
data with anyway
these jeremy corbell photos the ones
we're talking about the naval warships
they're they're white they're white
specks yeah i mean you see one of them
looks like pyramid i mean the navy were
tracking them though
and they did identify them as unknown it
was taught about multiple days moldable
ships
and the navy really has an incentive to
to not want to talk about this stuff
susan goff who leads the press effort at
the pentagon everything goes through her
i reached out to her today
about actually kind of jeremy corbell
stuff
through ncis goes back to her very
tightly controlled
i don't think it's so much that they're
trying to conceal alien bodies in the
basement i think they really don't
they don't know how to handle the issue
and it keeps happening and it's
escalating
so this this is not going away and again
journalistically i think it will do a
lot of favors for my career that i've
lent into it
you said on it's 99 likely that it's not
uh russian chinese or american where'd
you get that number that that's my
that's my uh assessment but i think it's
uh i'm very confident that it's the
assessment shared by
oni uh office of naval intelligence
which leads the investigative effort i i
personally i feel like it's more likely
that the navy's lying
then that extraterrestrials are arrived
just
mathematically if likelihood guess i
think you have to
yeah you have to trust um again uh
your sources you have to look at delib
platforms that are in place and we're
not just
that the thing that's interesting about
these and again looking at
the historic certainly with the
triangles um
the way these things behave non-jet
propulsion uh trans-medium travel
um hypersonic instantaneous acceleration
which would rip a human body apart
unless you have some kind of inertia
exactly
space time bubble potentially yeah which
might be that might be the
might be the things on the side of the
triangle maybe not but i think probably
is
um and again that's not me saying that
um
what in the starboard nacelles right but
it is
but but but the capabilities across the
board
multiple points right that you know
hypersonic
non-jet propulsion trans medium that
stuff is so far we don't have any of
that
well you could think it could be plasma
like a cloud of plasma being oh yeah but
then we have
we have debris surface imaging we have
debris metallic debris imagine so it
could be a meta material yeah
imagine someone in the 1800s trying to
explain a jet engine
and they'd be trying to use their
understanding of science
to explain futuristic technology
they wouldn't be thinking about these
combustion engines in the same way
or more importantly when we talk about
electricity
and then you go back and try and explain
it to someone in the pre you know
pre-electricity
they're not going to understand the
concept of how this works and so they're
going to try and use
their perspective on science you end up
with ideas like the ether you know what
i mean
they don't quite they can't pers they
can't conceptualize this stuff what
debris did they find
uh so the debris in terms of uh
metamaterial uh i don't know the i know
the us government has it i've heard that
from uh
two extremely good sources extremely
good
verified you know um that it
is um from
a crash location you know identified
something went down
recovered and the material analysis of
it there's a lot of different
elements of metamaterial that people say
are from ufos or uaps
and the the us government stuff there's
again chain of custody from siding crash
whatever um that because of the
metallurgy or the the binding of the
metals within it
uh it would be impossible to do with our
understanding of
um manufacturing uh and that it would
require at least
you know one very good source told me uh
again
and these are government people right
this is not some you know this is not
researchers who i think there are some
great researchers but i'm trying to be
very careful here about being able to
have a governmental link to what i'm
saying
um that that you could not produce it
where you're not in a zero
g zero gravity environment so space
um and so this is something that you
know other people have talked about with
that they say
you know metal analysis um but
you know again when you when you've got
um
the radar returns the icbm satellites
that we in case china just decides to
nuke us in the middle of the night that
we can track it
you've got this stuff coming into orbit
you know you've got it the nuclear
attack submarines catching it underwater
at hundreds of knots
um got it in the air you've got the
pilot seeing it
um you've got infrared um you have
you know just a gamut of sensor data
matched up
at least in limited circumstances to you
know
metallurgical analysis um
you know this is really something going
on here and again it it's better
actually though to
say right who the hell is tom rogan you
know the the marco rubio
the people are leaning into this um
you know it's it's it's something is
going on and yeah
and and that's and and you know time
will tell i mean i do that metallurgical
analysis right that that is very hard to
as someone told me avoid the physics
just just just kind of
you know uh focus on it's really
interesting and and
here's what we know it's a div it but
it's the seal has been broken now though
right
and and so it's seems like there are no
physics when it comes to the metal like
i have no
evidence of metallurgy for you to
to see yeah right and the government is
known lying to us like weapons of mass
destruction
yeah well i mean i i don't
intelligence failure um you know
could explain some of this but but again
when you have the cross-section
i i appreciate i suppose well i do
appreciate the fact that it's you know
i'm saying right that's what's
this my reporting um but you know i
could be
a liar uh and i could be being misled
he's trying to sell a book i think bob
lazar was misleading no i'm not writing
but yeah i just thought about zeta
reticuli
i don't believe bob i actually
personally don't believe him i think
he's yeah i don't believe him i think he
saw the craft that they were working on
the drones
but then they told him he said he was a
little green man yeah they
they probably they might have no i was a
puppy that guy
you got to be you know you've got to
talk to people who who
have the credentials and that's what
i've tried to focus on um
like what with lazar it seems like he
was working on a drone program
and that they told him it was aliens to
throw so that he didn't go and spew like
the government's working on drones
zeta reticuli it's nonsense
that now he looks like he's crazy right
it doesn't mean that they're working on
a drum program i mean they rated tesla's
laboratory in the 20s
i just think he that guy lacks
credibility yeah i did work his story he
did work sure
sure that's fine but his story's changed
and i'm not interested in someone
telling a story and being all smiling
confident about them coming out you know
23 years later
like oh actually that wasn't true
because back then it was sensational got
him on tv
today no one believes it so he takes
that part out of his story he said he
saw a little green man
yeah and i took that out i i was a
puppet
shut up i would say as well there i mean
i hope i i i think my reporting will
stand
uh on the merits but i would say a basic
place to start robert hastings ufos and
nukes
and david mahler triangle ufos those are
two very good
serious people who are just keeping it
to
eyewitnesses who have credibility and
doing their due diligence
and and it's fun it's fun it is it is i
believe maybe
maybe we'll actually get to the point
where we will discover what it is or
it'll be unveiled to the public but uh i
think we're gonna discover a lot more in
the coming years i think for sure
but i just don't i don't see aliens i
mean i have no no evidence even remote
evidence of aliens
well let's see what the audience thinks
over in the super chats if you haven't
already my friends
smash that like button and comment
because it really really does help you
basically tell on youtube you like the
show go to
cast.com become a member because we'll
have an exclusive members only segment
coming up
after the show over at timecast.com so
also subscribe
i think in the next couple of days we're
about to break one million subscribers
and then
you know and then in six months or
whatever they'll send us the golden
plaque again and then we'll put it on
the wall and we'll have it up there and
it'll be fun but
thanks so much everybody for subscribing
it's been it's been it's been a heck of
a ride so far and
here's to many more years to come let's
read some of these super chats
we got georgie georgev says hello guys
and subscribe to timcast.com keep it the
good work
also why not make a show where adam is a
guest it would be fun to see you guys
together for one show again at cheers
from east europe
perhaps there are some ideas floating
around we'll see how things roll but we
do have
a plan for friday night special episodes
that uh you know we'll see we'll see
what happens but we're getting the venue
set up
we're gonna have shows and maybe there
is something that unique will happen on
fridays
all right let's see ulysses says tim can
you explain why veritas hasn't been
canceled yet
it makes no sense to me because they're
bucking the narrative and exposing lies
but are still being allowed to produce
content
they got banned from twitter not that
long ago so
they're certainly trying but veritas is
on the level
they want it they want to claim they're
deceptive and all that and james o'keefe
comes out with the very
uh accurate point he just produces
videos of people with their mouth moving
if their mouth isn't moving he doesn't
produce the content
and he's correct there's a lot of
footage there's some where you can't see
their mouth move i get you get his point
the point is he has videos of people
saying things you want to say it's
deceptively edited or whatever
sorry man you're gonna have to do better
than that because other news
organizations do much worse
they say we have an anonymous source we
won't reveal to you
just trust us this is what they said at
least with james o'keefe you can see
somebody saying it that's a hundred
times more credible than our anonymous
source
said but they're trying to cancel them
all right common cure says small towns
are the future
here here all right let's see
where are we at
uh julie ann says would love if you
could have drew hernandez on
founder of live's matter independent
investigative journalist was just at
border about to uh
about to go to minneapolis we have had
joe on the show
multiple times yes drew's great he's
great i love him all right
good worker brett morgan says tim i want
to start a virginia chapter of tim cast
independent journalists
they and you can message me at
thecaptain251 on twitter
it is uh tim cast the independent media
broadcast
there you go
vgk stone says sup gang watch the show
every night love it
ian have you heard of the story up in
quebec canada right now with graphene in
the
in the blue surgical masks health canada
put out a recall on blue surgical masks
yeah someone sent me a message about
that i didn't read into it though
interesting really i laughed when i read
it that's crazy
opossum says i fear no matter what comes
out people will never wake up i have
three close friends and i send them
things disproving the corporate
narrative and they still don't see it
they say willful ignorance yup
that's the problem
all right let's see where we at matt
daniel says yo tim i got into crypto
after hearing you talk about it during
the gamestop
stock thing in january i invested in
doge and it's gone up like 900 percent
now what's those yet
uh i didn't look today i'll check it out
bitcoins at 63
000 times yeah ethereum too what's
ethereum at
uh 2300. wow
remember we had bill on the show and he
was like you should he was like
ethereum sounds like it's a good idea
not financial advice
yes and then i was like okay i'll buy
some crypto sounds like they're very
happy about that
financial advice tell me what those
dozers at 10 cents 11 cents
11 cents wasn't it at like four or
something it was point zero zero zero
zero zero four cents like
last year or something i don't know yeah
i was at fourth century imagine being a
dogecoin millionaire
you know i made my first million in
dogecoin
the name is befitting yes a millionaire
status yes ronald asharov says brian
salter has been demoted to making tucker
carlson reaction videos
true though yeah that's true that's
unfortunately
omg puppy says moore's suppressed planet
of the humans is interesting look at
corruption of green energy industry
biomass power plants burn trees showcase
solar farms
are abandoned ruins mining and fossil
fuel
use behind all green tech
interesting all right let's see what we
got
josh l says can sub stack become youtube
for writing
well the issue is the the difference
between sub stack and youtube in general
is that youtube has
advertising propping it up so if you're
on youtube
ads run on the content you make money
you've also got uh
super chats and things like that for
live streams but the membership function
for youtube is not that great
uh subset is very different and they're
actually writing checks to people to get
them to come over
so it won't be the youtube of writing i
think medium tried to do that and it
wasn't as effective
the thing about substance is they found
a way to create a career for people out
of it so it's more like patreon with a
focus on writing
i should clarify doge was .002 cents
a year ago so it is appreciated 50 times
in the last year
impressive all right let's see
zermas playground says amazon can't even
go a month without becoming more
totalitarian
they forced facial recognition login
then they installed cameras that watch
everything you do
and will even text you text your boss if
you yawn
now there's a wrong think policy we have
to sign what is that true
if you yawn your boss gets a text about
where's that at
amazon jeez well i'll tell you this if
it were me
i would quit yep i'd rather just
live under a tree in the middle of the
woods and go fishing down by the river
man i don't know for people that need
money right now what do you need money
for
family food family feed your kids plenty
of fish in the sea
pay for your house what did what what
did what did our ancestors do did they
go like rats i need money a bunch of
native americans
or did they just go like i'm going to
kill a deer and eat it feed my family
if they could catch it yeah they could
sometimes
there aren't many deer in the inner city
there's a lot of starvation back then
that's the problem man don't live in
these cities
you come out in the middle of nowhere
and the deer are a problem it is
yeah yeah i've got a lot of the people
at the gun shop they're like you have a
deer a lot of junior property i'm like
oh tons and they're like
we can deal with them for you i'm like
they don't bother me because
they're not destroying any of our crops
like everything like that but for a lot
of people that is a problem
when they have like fruit trees and the
deer come and just tear it all up and
stuff like that and there's too many of
them
so hunting is literally because there's
too many deer
you gotta keep the numbers in check
interestingly though i i was reading
once about how they reintroduced wolves
to like the yellowstone
area and the wolves keep the numbers in
check and restore balance
it's really interesting we need some
hunting of foxes
in london yeah i thought pat tortoise
was killed by a
fox one richard cook
says tom the bbc news app slants every
story with race baiting style commentary
they do report facts but in an
asymmetric way leaving out the race of
an alleged criminal
when they are not white it's not good
not perfect but
you know i think it's it's it's a pretty
good place i think you made the good
point you've got
you've got to read around exactly you
can't go to look i'll tell you this you
go to the bbc read an article
you need to fact check what you're
reading you know and i and i do think
you know and i'm sure
hopefully it will be replicated so
there's more competition but one good
thing where google really does deserve a
positive shout out
is the google translate because going on
you could go on comment you know
russian newspaper you know just hitting
that button
yeah maybe it's not going to be entirely
accurate but it gives you an idea of
foreign media do you know about
um bbc pidgin no a lot of people are
surprised to find this pigeon
is i think it's like west african uh oh
sure
english yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's like
uh
phonetic i guess what do they call
ebonic english is it right
and a lot of people read it thinking
it's a different language and then they
realize it's actually english
right but it's just crazy english so
yeah yeah
pidgin english it's really interesting
but like the bbc
it's like a funded hype you know
newsroom
writing this style is interesting crazy
all right
nevits wc says i see you want to get
into entertainment like movies and
television
would you ever consider getting into
graphic novels i'm writing one because
of my beliefs i don't want it published
by the woke
yes absolutely yeah um yeah
you know you know who's amazing is um oh
man
i'm forgetting the name and his books
are right downstairs
george uh jinji ido oh yeah we have like
tons of junji ido graphic novel manga
killer horror story crazy
really creepy some of the best horror
i've ever read i was twisting my mind
to try and read through those what it
was it was twisting your mind it was it
was
rough it's amazing a different person
when i finished the first
yeah dude brilliant brilliant stuff
dixie normis
says haha tim why are you hating on juan
division so much elizabeth olsen is my
queen
because this like the first three
episodes are trash they're not even real
it's not even a real show
just waste our time and then the next
several episodes are okay
but she's the bad guy i thought it was
going to be revealed that she was being
manipulated i thought it was going to be
like
oh it turns out she was being
manipulated and to do all this oh no
she's just evil
she's literally just torturing people
who beg for death
she's the bad guy how is agga that's
supposed to be the bad guy when she's
like how are you doing this
i want your power i'm like okay if there
was someone who was torturing thousands
of people
and you said i want to take away your
ability to torture them
i guess she wanted it for herself that's
still kind of bad but you know
what did you think of the witcher the tv
i didn't watch it i didn't see it
i'll say what i thought about it i
turned it on watched a few minutes and
then turned it off okay
all right sorry i'll leave that there
yeah i'm not trying to say it was a bad
show i'm saying i just
couldn't yeah all right yeah yeah i'll
be honest i did the same thing with the
video game
i played the first 15 minutes and then i
was like yeah i hear it's amazing and i
just can't get through me too i played
the first one i put it down
picked up the second one i was like i
should beat the first one first i put it
down picked up the third one
played it for like two 20 hours but i
barely scratched the surface right
right dead redemption too i'm going to
get on that it's good
my brother knows that it's cool that you
can experience like an old west town
like southern like louisiana in the
1850s and it's almost like a vr reality
where you get to be there
and see the sound hear the sounds and
see it that's cool
richard cook just followed up he said
you missed my point i can easily surf
around for the truth however
the masses will not do that this is what
deranges the population
no i i agree when that's basically the
point i was saying
yeah a discerning individual someone
who's politically initiated
will know how to spot the pitfall media
literacy we know how to spot the
pitfalls when we're reading a story and
we see the slant in the bias
how do we solve for the fact that these
organizations don't do that
education yeah really gonna happen yeah
yeah
cody moons has been watching since the
first time i saw you on crowder keep it
the good work hey you appreciate it
infinity flair says great take tim i
live in seattle and wish the police
would take up your suggestion
let the enlightened left put their own
lives on the line
i just could you imagine what would
happen i like your idea
the cops give notice all right everybody
in in 14 days
we will officially resign all at once
you give it a week word travels around
and then people are gonna be
no no no there's gonna be like flowers
and fruit baskets and chocolates being
mailed to the cops
it's it's also interesting i was
thinking about this that that the way we
described that i bet
you know i i if it was sort of gonna be
reported you know in
left-wing media they would say that it
was we were calling for
you know the plea we should go back to
the days where the police could just do
whatever they wanted no accountability
what we're actually just suggesting is
just accountable policing
but like the the balance of law being
you know predicated on you know the
innocent until proven guilty being
treated fairly they say you know and we
and we have uh people who are just
spoiled
they're so used to the cops actually
dealing with
a lot of this crime and dealing with let
me let me slow down
my dad was a firefighter and he said son
you never want to be a cop they work
awful hours and man is it a skit it's
like a miserable job
everybody you see the worst of people
every single day you're in your car and
you get a call some nasty person's doing
something nasty and you got to deal with
this every single day
people think the cops spend most their
day what like writing tickets a lot of
cops spend a lot of their days in these
cities
dealing with violent deranged
individuals who won't listen
or breaking the law it's a nasty job
domestic violence
and now a lot of these a lot of people
are just accustomed to the ease
that you know the police are a deterrent
in many ways
and so when crime happens they don't see
it they know
that they don't need to have guns in
their house because the cops are just a
phone call away
right well what happens when the cops
are like all right you won't support us
that's fine we'll leave call 9-1-1
yeah well i love it when the guys when
the guy fell off the building
the anti-police activists who get hurt
then go help call the police i feel for
ems man because if the cops resign and
we rely everyone call 9-1-1 it's going
to be
great do you see the video there's a
video of these antifa people
leaving a riot and they're crossing a
bridge when they
like throw something at a car and then
the guy like jumps out and he's armed or
something yeah
and they're really yeah they're like
call the police
oh yeah okay i i i would love to see
that cop walk out and be like you guys
are upset nah you're good
you don't need me right you want i got
fired i'm out later it's like there's
that
that moment in the novel when finally
the police are gone
and all the protesters realize
that the totalitarian military
dictatorship that took the place of the
police that's
abusing beating and murdering them that
it's not that good
and like that you feel like good they've
now they're getting
just desserts now they're getting killed
by the corrupt
like and like you want to see them
suffer for their idiocy
but i don't want that in society because
we'll be left with a military
dictatorship
they're they're they're not i said it
would be only a few days before they're
begging the police and the police are
right there
saying okay okay we're here that's why i
said his idea was better
putting a notice out saying in 30 days
we're done
you you will see how quickly people
immediately no no wait wait wait wait
wait we take it back we take it back we
don't want to bosh the police
they abolished the police in minneapolis
and then panicked
as phone calls started coming in saying
there's crime no one's stopping it the
police won't respond anymore
right it was it was panic it was chaos
crime was skyrocketing
if the police just said okay we've heard
from the activists
the mayors are mad at us the politicians
are scapegoating us the democrats hate
our guts
we're gonna we're out it's all you guys
we're gonna go be firefighters or we're
gonna go we're construction or something
the residents of these cities trump i'll
tell you this
if every cop in minneapolis
resigned the moment their their you know
third person or whatever burnt to the
ground
i bet trump would have won minnesota
right right
if the police said i watched that video
the cops running out of the police
precinct as it's being burnt to the
ground as people one guy stole a bunch
of police gear
and these cops some many of them quit
like in general
most of them just stayed and then
said we know that we're being abused by
our own government
we know that many of the people in the
city refuse to defend us or stand up for
us but don't worry
we're not going anywhere that's crazy to
me if they said
you get what you asked for the people
have now voted for this
minnesota was blue right it voted for a
democrat
okay the police have now understood
not only does do people not support them
but they actually vote in the same
people
who smear sacrifice or just you know try
and
scapegoat them and they're still there
that's amazing
that's amazing to me i kind of feel like
hey at a certain point when someone says
we don't want you here you get
you get the hint maybe you should just
go
if the cops stood up last year
what's happening today wouldn't be
happening these rides wouldn't be
happening
it's a wonderful life all right we got w
cash says i'm a follower of the daily
wire and tim cast
found out about you from the joe rogan
twitter podcast so glad i did
when can one of the daily wire hosts
join your podcast i'd love the range of
ideas
that's a great question yeah i'm really
curious when we might be able to do that
i don't know the exact date that i do
[Laughter]
is it soon it's the 23rd oh really yeah
it is oh wow it's really soon
that's gonna be great and you guys don't
know who it is
everyone's gonna just say it's ben
shapiro yeah no all right libertatum
says cops enforce unconstitutional laws
politicians push
if they don't uphold their oath the
constitution they must be removed and
should be held liable just as medical
are to the hippocratic oath
i think if a politician says officer
violate the constitution the officer
should say i can't do that
i was told not to do that that's what it
is in the military it's an unlawful
order it's a duty to disobey
right yes what if we what if we have
states pass laws saying that if a police
officer acts against the constitution
that's a criminal charge
make a statutory law a criminal offense
a misdemeanor for constitutional
violation
yeah i mean yeah you're going to have to
develop case law though so the police
know how to operate in
high stress you know time-sensitive
environments right
yeah i mean i i take your point i mean
that's still exit right there's civil
rights violations the fbi can
investigate but
yeah perhaps the balance of um
investigative interest is not where it
should be
seth shumake says looks like y'all are
on track at a million before the weekend
thank you for being instrumental in
turning the tide special thanks to ian
for being the show's protagonist
see the rlm definition what does that
mean
thanks dude sergeant wolfe says it's
events like this with dante wright that
make me want to be a cop
but it's also what make me never want to
be a cop i want to help my community but
how can i do that if i'm going to be
targeted or tar and feathered for it
it's just really simple if you have a
community
and a large portion not the majority but
a large portion
i guess the plurality is saying down
with cops cops are bad
then the next larger group just says we
don't care
we don't care about you at all okay well
then the vote is in
abstained cops are bad there you go stop
supporting those people
the civic nationalist says from one brit
to another bet the weather ain't balls
across the pond
but the bobbies need better training
also try to give the yank some bans
but you can leave it to the to the
members bit god save the queen
long live britain do you understand any
of that yeah i
understand of it speaking
speak in britain gaiden says tim
federalizing the police is a terrible
outcome
and the desired one if the police are no
longer accountable to their local
governments
and communities i agree with that the
challenge is there are periods in which
the federal government intervenes when
people's rights aren't being upheld
when extremists are burning down
people's property and
your local government is laughing in
your face refusing to do anything and
supporting the extremists
that's when the federal government is
supposed to come in to protect your
rights
so when the federal government deputized
the state police it was in protection of
the rights of those who lived there
not it you know in in contrast
yeah not oppression there was no
usurpation involved
as far as i can tell all right noah poa
says my uncle got the johnson johnson
vaccine just some days ago
he had a stroke due to blockage he has
no history of blood issues it's kind of
eye-opening when something perceived as
rare happens to someone you know
personally
was that registered as one of the cases
because you said uncle and according to
the news it was only women
i believe it was uh it was what eight
women or so mostly yeah five or six
women i think
okay so maybe maybe that was then don't
know
emily mower says look it up tim you
don't know what you're talking about
european union
equals confederal united states equals
federal history of books are written by
the victors
okay oh i see many many get up
rasgriz says i'm willing to compromise
with rashida taleb we can get rid of
policing starting with the atf
the history of gun control is
unironically a history of discrimination
against freed slaves and other
minorities
agreed seconded moving on
no i absolutely agree uh yeah i don't
really understand why that
and the positive things that they do
which there are i would see you know
explosive you know terrorist groups why
that can't be
enveloped into the fbi yeah
break up the atf break it apart alcohol
it's dhs you see that they're selling
plush dogs
the atf announced their new store as
well off responses and then there's like
uh a picture of like a shirt and then
like a plush dog
and i was gonna tweet a joke about it
but i was like it's too dark too dirty
dhs is a big waste of money as well
just get good i'm with you man in what
way bureaucracy
it creates and creates it slows down the
process
uh the counterterrorism stuff they do
which is the sort of reason that
is not well regarded in the intelligence
community but what are you saying like
bring all these departments under one
like have run by the fbi yeah
i mean honestly dhs you could get rid of
a lot of it because it's just
replicating it's like the
director of national intelligence you're
replicating things
and the idea that it's going to make you
know but ice is part of
ice and cbp rdhs okay so no so just have
them without the
you know the superstructure of the dhs
right have them as they were before dhs
which was what 2003 doesn't it doesn't
it actually
bring it all under one umbrella and
easier to control when the departments
are part of one agency instead of
i don't think so and i think it creates
you you're creating
a management structure that goes above
and beyond you know ice doesn't simply
it doesn't you know decision making is
slowed down because you can't you've got
to keep going after that
and you put the higher you go the more
political it becomes sometimes you want
these things just to
be left to do to their own devices
unless they screw up this is a lot of
what we heard from
the squad to get rid of dhs and then all
these agencies out of them
yeah i mean honestly secret service
if you have uh them back in the treasury
ice
functioning more independently they
probably move more quickly like you were
saying right all right let's see
jason dixon says doge broke 10 cents
diamond hands to the moon
oh there you go all right
jp mcglone says tim i'll stand up with
you let's go all right let's stand up
all right everybody stand up i'm kidding
standing okay okay
we're standing everyone no more chairs
on the team question
strong says tim stop being lazy you have
a dev team and a super chat problem
if biden dislikes can be tracked you can
have the super chats tracked and logged
with your own program
what does that reference to hmm i don't
know you have a def
super chat problem we do oh we can't get
to all of them i don't know
i mean there's not enough time in the
day to read every single super chat is
that the issue
i entreat you to flesh out that comment
because i want to know what you're
talking about
the god pill says tim talking about
standing up and doing something as he
ignores the war that is gme and amc and
tim did nothing
i did several segments on gamestop
stunts and we talked about it quite a
bit yeah a lot we actually built a shirt
uh yeah i literally have the diamond
hands gorilla shirt that we've been
constantly talking about gamestop it's
right there
yeah it's a misprint it's a misprint
it's the the ink is it's funny that we
keep showing the misprint on the show
but it's a it's a gorilla holding cash
because you know apes together strong
right right yeah i guess i guess we did
nothing but we're good capitalists who
made money on it
there you go you're welcome troy
dingman says instead of cash bail why
don't they let off these non-violent
crimes with an ankle bracelet so they
can track their movements
and if they get caught then you hold
them that's what i was saying right
it's like okay we're not going to hold
you but you get an ankle bracelet
and then you have a conditional release
there you go i mean but yeah i mean if
you're sort of breaking into a car and
stuff that you should be you know
bail uh but doesn't mean you know you
shouldn't
have judicial consequences this is why
body cameras are important you know why
because when this guy gets caught again
on camera
with a you know slim jim in a car the
cop can be like i'm literally filming
you do this
you're not going to get you know bailed
out this time exactly and good cops
that's why good cops like those cameras
yes
right and then the reason they don't if
you talk to them is that they're worried
that you know when they're in the car
being like that you know you see that
video of the cop planting drugs
yes he thought he was turning his camera
off but he turned it on yes
and then he planted drugs dude that was
florida i think wasn't it
i don't know i don't think so yeah
that's scary stuff man what do you
wonder how much that's happened before
you know that happens a lot oh yeah it
happens a lot
what do you do when you're like minding
your own business and the cop walks up
to and says look what i found a cop that
thinks the ends
justify the means is terrifying are
there just evil people who want to get
the career marks and make money ah
that's crazy
yeah people they're bad people you know
what i mean and that's why i think as
well we need we do need to hire more
uh public defenders you know because if
if that happens
perhaps to one of us you know we might
have the money to to go and get a lawyer
and and to create public attention
but if you're some kid who's has no
money yeah
public defender does not have enough
time because then the cops can say hey
plea it down to misdemeanor would it
take it
because i do not i got to go and work on
50 other cases
today yeah sunny james says so tired of
manufactured outraged
is this what happens when a service
economy dies like open borders people
arguing for a two-day state
a two-state solution in israel or green
passports my mind can no longer vomit
the hypocrisy up no more
this was something tucker carlson
covered tucker carlson did this big
segment where he said
demographic change is a democratic
strategy to win votes
and he's basically saying when
immigrants come in
they're more likely to vote democrat and
that means places like california which
were reliably republican until you know
1988
became democrat you know from 92 on
and it's because they brought in more
and more immigrants and ronald reagan
was the one who signed it
he got called the white white
nationalist all these journalists are
like he's clearly just the white
nationalist
even though dr carlson literally said
black americans are the most
negatively impacted by the displacement
the loss of jobs and immigration
it's it's the propaganda but we saw in
2020 actually his
hispanic vote is going much more for
trump than was anticipated probably
because of this too but
the the the interesting point that
tucker ends up bringing up is that the
anti-defamation league themselves
argue against the same thing for the
same
they basically you you could take what
the anti-defamation league said
and claim it came from tucker carlson
and you'd be like i believe it
because they were like israel should not
allow palestinians to come into their
borders because it would displace the
ethnic jews from their state and it's
like
okay and then they accused that they
demanded tucker carlson quit or be fired
for being a white nationalist when it's
like
he just repeated what you guys said
about israel right so it's clearly
just an illegitimate argument all right
let's see where we're at
rain miller says tim i would love to
hear you weigh on china flying 25
warplanes over taiwan
these are syria there are serious issues
in europe right now too war with russia
and china under biden is much more
likely than before we will talk about
that in the bonus segment coming up
because uh you're also a foreign policy
guy right do we have a lot to talk about
with china too
all right let's see we got we will
handle a few more of these super chats
and uh chris rohrbach says ian what are
your thoughts on dogecoin
well it's it's kind of a comedy coin but
uh lex
lex freeman and elon musk love it and
tweet about it nonstop so
i imagine it's a i'm not much of a
financial advisor but
you know the popular coins tend to go up
in value
waffle sensei says tim if you
coordinated to help start a legal
defense group for
inner city black gun ownership the minds
of these double thinkers would explode
a rip and rip a tear in the multiverse
let's
let's let's f get to it
i'm not kidding get some more ufos then
yeah i'm absolutely serious so
no i think it's a good idea i've reached
out to some people well my issue for
first is like i don't want to only be
like racially targeted i don't want it
to be like oh we're gonna help inner
city
black youth about their guns i think
it's just about people in cities
whose only crime was possession of a
firearm and defending them but i do
think starting in chicago
would be very important because like i
said i know people who are good people
good family people and they're like
what am i supposed to do and they're so
prohibitive there
and and the law abiding citizens are
like okay i won't get a gun and the gang
gangs come out shoot up houses
drive-bys not even all gangs a lot of
people are just reckless
and so we wanted to find the people the
right to keep and bear arms
and that means even in their own home
but the idea that they have to go
through these you know these laws or
whatever i think would be fun to defend
them
and it'll be really really fascinating
to see how the democratic politicians of
chicago
handle defending this guy like we're
going to take people we're gonna be like
here's a guy who works construction
he's got two kids he's in his late 20s
he has a wife he's trying his hardest to
raise them right
and he decided to protect himself
because of the high gun crime in the
city by getting himself a gun
the constitution says he can we're going
to defend him all the way what are the
no no this man should be in prison his
kids should go without a father
i'd love to see him say that no i think
we'd actually help a lot of people
i think the political pressure would
result in a lot of these a lot of these
people having their charges dropped
i don't know if the nra does that i've
heard stories where the nra does
in some cases but typically it's like
suburban women right you know those are
the stories i end up hearing
so i'm dead serious about that we'll see
what we can end up pulling off
all right let's see let's uh let's let's
take this one
we'll take one more roy cantu says tim
i've been watching some older vids when
your ideology began to shift and the
left started to turn on you
how did it make you feel and did you
ever think about calling it quits what
made you decide to keep going
i don't think that my ideology shifted
enough to where i ever actually cared
about what they thought
when i worked for a few when i worked
for vice vice was a very libertarian
place
when i worked for a fusion they were so
they were they claimed they were trying
to be and then they got woke
i remember i made a video about why it
was wrong to have
uh it was like harvard did a black only
graduation and i was like segregation i
don't like it
and a bunch of people at fusion got
angry that i said this and they were
complaining about it and i'm like why
do you want to segregate the races
apparently they did
so my positions have always been you
know for the most part in a similar
place now there are some things i've
like 2a for for sure i'm like very very
pro-gun these days
so you know that but uh the true left
they're pro-gun the authoritarian left
is pro-gun because they need it to stage
their revolution to install their
utopian communist vision
and the libertarian left is pro-gun
because they want to tear down the
system
and the libertarian right is pro-gun
because
second amendment constitution free
markets and all that stuff the
authoritarian right is anti-gun
that's interesting well maybe not every
authoritarian right
it's like the center-right authoritarian
spectrum of where the democrats are
they hate guns all right my friends
we're gonna have a bonus segment
the members only exclusive segment
coming up at you i'm sorry coming up at
timcast.com
so go there become a member smash that
like button and subscribe to this show
and tell your friends about it because
we're about to break one million
subscribers and when we do
youtube is going to send us this big
beautiful golden plaque we're going to
hang it up
and uh yeah how about that
maybe then we'll get banned who knows
but uh that's why you go to tps.com
support us you can follow me on all
social media platforms at tim cast
my other youtube channels are
youtube.com timcast and
youtube.comcastnews
this show is live monday to friday at
8pm so thanks for hanging out tom you
want to shout anything out no
i've really had a great time and uh
twitter account
yeah tomorrow tweets is my twitter
account and uh yeah
just had fun this is great right on i
agree man and i only wish we could have
talked more about ufos and uaps because
that was
i was jealous but that's that's that's
coming up
in the members only oh yeah and i would
say just as a concluding comment though
on that you know a lot of that stuff
right is stuff um
you know took to work on and produce and
bring out
um flesh out more so you know hopefully
hopefully people won't
you know just think why is this guy just
mouthing off all this stuff yeah yeah
yeah
but yeah yeah yeah no you're right uh
you call me ian crossland.net
there you go boom yeah and i am sarah
patrick super excited about hitting a
million very excited about our guest on
the 23rd that you guys have tuned in for
it is not ben shapiro
i am sour patch lids on twitter and
minds follow me there we're gonna be
talking about
china a new report says that they're
basically the biggest threat
we're gonna talk about that and it's
going to lead into probably more ufo
talks so make sure you go to timcast.com
become a maverick because that should be
up in about one hour and we will see you
all then bye guys
you